We running this, let's go! I'm on a boat! I'm on a boat! Everybody look at me, cause I'm sailing on a boat! I'm on a boat! I'm on a boat! Take a good hard look... Captain's Log, Stardate, December 4th, 2023. Coming to you live from a boat with Carolyn Robistow. We're talking about gray area drinking,
我们要出发了，走吧！我在船上！我在船上！大家都看着我，因为我在船上航行！我在船上！我在船上！好好看清楚……船长日志，星历，2023年12月4日。现在正与卡罗琳·罗比斯托（Carolyn Robistow）在船上为您直播。我们正在讨论“灰色地带饮酒”，
and using brain spotting to reduce drinking and during life coaching i am i'm wearing my i'm on a boat shirt like i told you and the uh for for audio listeners i'm actually not kidding about what's going on in the video this time carolyn is on a boat um i am on a boat it is not the start date it's a water boat not a do you keep the captain's log like do you to, or does the electronics do that for you now? Is there a black box on boats? How does this work? Yes and yes. So you don't have to, unless you're a, and speaking of I'm on a boat now, like the noisiest things are going to be around me and trying to maintain minimal noises.
以及利用脑点定位（brain spotting）来减少饮酒。在生活辅导期间，我穿着我那件“我在船上”的T恤，正如我告诉过你们的那样。对于音频听众，我这次真的没开玩笑，视频里卡罗琳确实在船上。嗯，我是在船上，这不是星历，这是一艘水上船。你还在记船长日志吗？还是现在电子设备帮你做了？船上有黑匣子吗？这怎么运作？是的，都有。所以你不需要自己记，除非你是……说到“我在船上”，我周围最吵的东西可能会干扰我，我正试图保持最小的噪音。
It's a podcast of erite. Yes. It's what we strive for. If anything is so loud, it's problematic. Just let me know and I'll see if I can do something about it. So if you're a licensed captain, you have to keep a captain's log. Neither of us are licensed captains yet. Do you have a quill?
这是一个精英播客。是的，这是我们追求的目标。如果有什么声音太大，那就有问题了。只要告诉我，我会看看能不能处理。所以如果你是一名持证船长，你必须保存船长日志。我们俩还不是持证船长。你有羽毛笔吗？
Do I have a quill? I have a pointer. I have a brain spotting pointer always nearby. Does that count? Maybe I should put a feather on it. So is it a digital type thing where you dock and whatever, just in case the boat is found adrift? I do.
我有羽毛笔吗？我有一个指针。我身边总是有个脑点定位指针。那算吗？也许我应该在上面插根羽毛。所以这是一种数字化的东西，当你停靠时，以防船只漂流时被发现？是的。
I keep it on my iPad just because that's where I take all of my notes for all of the things. But I did get my husband like a nice branded bound captain's log that has like the boat name kind of you know embossed on it it's really fancy is it like a like driving a cdl like truck like do they they audit your log or you're just supposed to have it if you're um i don't know because we haven't done that in the captain's license train i'm sure when you get your captain's license they'll tell you what you have to have it for but really for us it's gorgeous because we want to be able to remember and even then we talked about how
我把它保存在iPad上，因为我所有的笔记都在那里。但我确实给我丈夫买了一个漂亮的品牌装订船长日志，上面压印着船名，非常精致。这就像开CDL卡车一样吗？他们会审计你的日志，还是说你只是应该有它？我不知道，因为我们还没进行船长执照培训。我相信当你拿到船长执照时，他们会告诉你为什么要用它。但对我们来说，它很棒，因为我们想记住这一切。即便如此，我们之前也谈到过，
we have been on the boat for close to three months now and already i'm like where were we when that happened what was going on wasn't that this person and it is already running together so makes sense that you wouldn't yeah and pirates is that a thing like any any like related it is yeah pirates are a thing we've not been in waters where pirates are we've done all of our traveling so far in the atlantic uh intercoastal waterway so we've been kind of if you imagine like a boat freeway that actually cuts through land that people really only are aware of if they live in the area and so there's always been like a slice of land and then the ocean we've not gone people kind of talk about it like are you on the outside or the inside when you're traveling and
我们在船上已经快三个月了，我已经开始想：那件事发生时我们在哪？当时发生了什么？那不是某某人吗？事情已经混在一起了。所以你不会记日志也说得通。还有海盗，那是真的吗？有相关的吗？是的，海盗是真实存在的。我们还没去过有海盗的水域。到目前为止，我们所有的旅行都在大西洋内陆水道。如果你想象一条实际上穿过陆地的船只高速公路，只有住在附近的人才知道。所以总有一片陆地，然后是海洋。我们还没去过……人们谈论它时会问：“你是在外侧还是内侧航行？”
we have only thus far traveled on the inside what's it called when you go like all the way up the coast and then down the mississippi river and make like a loop around half the country there's like some like club of people that do the loop oh yeah we're in that club that's we're starting in the spring we're in you get you get stuck certain places where there's like not gas and provisions like you have to prepare that's that's wild yeah it's called the great loop the club is america's great loop cruisers associate agl seattle something like that but we are in it but yeah i think that we have like uh exhausted as much as i know boats that is fascinating yeah so carolyn life coaches and brain spots and does a lot of uh cool work
到目前为止，我们只在内侧航行。当你沿着海岸一直走，然后顺着密西西比河走，绕过半个国家，那叫什么？好像有个俱乐部的人会做这个环线。哦，是的，我们在那个俱乐部。我们春天就要开始了。你在某些地方会被困住，那里没有燃料和补给，你必须做好准备。那太疯狂了。是的，这叫“大环线”（Great Loop）。俱乐部是“美国大环线巡航者协会”（AGLCA），大概是这样。但我们确实在里面。不过，我想我已经耗尽了我所知道的关于船的一切，这太迷人了。是的，所以卡罗琳做生活辅导和脑点定位，做很多很酷的工作，
from a boat which means that she can can see you internationally or outside of Alabama, unlike me. So I wanted to not only because I like her podcast, and I like some of the stuff that she's put out there, but also make it available to people who email me outside of the state of Alabama and ask me to see them for brain spotting. Because if you're in Alabama, there's a little bit of a wait list for Taproot. And if you're outside of Alabama, I'm sorry, but we're not able to see you at all ever. But Carolyn can and she does, you know, a lot of the same stuff, but more specific stuff than we do. So that's exciting. So, like, can you go through a little bit of, like, your approach and the services you offer and how all that stuff works?
在船上进行，这意味着她可以在国际上或阿拉巴马州以外的地方见你，不像我。所以我不仅是因为我喜欢她的播客，喜欢她发布的一些内容，还想让阿拉巴马州以外给我发邮件、要求进行脑点定位的人也能接触到她。因为如果你在阿拉巴马州，Taproot（机构名）的候补名单有点长。如果你在阿拉巴马州以外，很抱歉，我们根本无法见你。但卡罗琳可以，她也确实在做，你知道，很多和我们一样的事情，但比我们更具体。这很令人兴奋。那么，你能简单介绍一下你的方法、你提供的服务以及这一切是如何运作的吗？
Absolutely. My approach. Well, let me back it up. We always joke that there's like two therapy profiles that you can write. And one of them is like specializing in complex trauma for the sensitive trained in the CBT for the focus of is like, sometimes life is an ocean that becomes a beach. But when it is a mountain, the streams of our thoughts don't meet the iceberg of our heart in the same way. And those are like the two. They are. I'll tell you now. Okay.
当然。我的方法。嗯，让我倒退一下。我们总是开玩笑说，你可以写两种治疗简介。其中一种是专门针对敏感人群的复杂创伤，接受过CBT培训，重点是……有时生活是一片海洋，变成了一片沙滩。但当它是一座山时，我们思想的溪流并不能以同样的方式汇入我们心灵的冰山。这就是那两种。确实是。我现在就告诉你。好的。
Mentally, I'm going to compose my psychology today profile because I don't have one anymore. I stopped. I took it down when I stopped seeing clients and moved just to coaching. So I tell you that he tries to help you out because instead of just like write about what you do, which they mess up, they're like, describe your ideal client. And then it'll tell you how they're going to format it. So when it smushes it together in a paragraph, it kind of has the flow of good copy editing. But describe your ideal client. Just it's such a funny phrase to me like yeah i'll tell you my if i had a profile today it would start with in the immortal words of l woods
在心理上，我正准备撰写我的“今日心理学”（Psychology Today）简介，因为我不再有简介了。我停止见客户并转为纯辅导后就撤掉了。所以我告诉你，他试图帮你，因为他们不是让你写你做什么（他们会搞砸），而是让你描述你的理想客户。然后它会告诉你如何排版。所以当它把内容压缩成一段时，它有一种好的文案编辑的流畅感。但描述你的理想客户……对我来说这是一个非常有趣的短语。如果我今天有简介，它会以《律政俏佳人》中艾尔·伍兹（Elle Woods）的不朽名言开头：
after getting into harvard law what like like it's hard? Except we'd be saying it about changing habits and our relationship with alcohol and perfectionism. I think those are kind of my main things. But what I love is specifically about how I've woven in brain spotting with this, you know, kind of traditional coaching work is that it does make it where people are like, Oh, God, that was so much easier than I expected. Not that it makes it easy per se. But it just, and this is so funny to use this, this phrase, because it is so often associated with drinking, but I feel like brain spotting takes the edge off of this work. It just takes the edge off. So it's not quite as intense or hard for people to make the changes
在进入哈佛法学院之后，说什么？“这很难？”除了我们会说这是关于改变习惯、我们与酒精的关系以及完美主义。我认为这些是我的主要内容。但我特别喜欢的是我如何将脑点定位与这种传统的辅导工作结合起来，它确实让人们觉得：“天哪，这比我预期的容易多了。”并不是说它本身很容易。但它只是……用这个短语很滑稽，因为它经常与饮酒联系在一起，但我感觉脑点定位减轻了这项工作的压力。它只是减轻了压力。所以人们做出他们想要的改变并没有那么强烈或困难，
that they want to come and make or any, any type of subcortical. I say brain spotting, cause it's the one that I use the most, but what I mean is any type of brain body-based subcortical focused process. I think that's my favorite uh line from Breaking Bad is where like all the guys are sitting around in the basement they're like does anyone have any meth and everyone looks at him and he's like just enough to take the edge off yeah exactly you know actually just enough to take the edge off but yeah so that's that's how I would start my psychology today profile I think well. Yeah, and I think that's it. There's so many people assume that it's about intellect or knowing something or having information or being told what to do or a list of steps.
或者任何类型的皮层下过程。我说脑点定位，是因为我用得最多，但我指的是任何类型的基于脑-身体的皮层下聚焦过程。我想这是我最喜欢的《绝命毒师》台词，那些人在地下室坐着，有人问：“有人有冰毒吗？”每个人都看着他，他说：“只要一点点，减轻压力就行。”是的，完全正确。你知道，其实只要一点点来减轻压力。所以，这就是我开始我的“今日心理学”简介的方式。我想是的。而且我认为就是这样。有太多人认为这关乎智力、了解某事、拥有信息、被告知该做什么或一份步骤清单。
And I don't know, maybe in 1955. But at this point, we've all seen The Sopranos. We sort of have intuited the CBT. We sort of have intuited the stereotype of we sort of have intuited the stereotype of psychoanalysis that arguably is psychoanalysis like we know that information we just need our brain to feel different you know like I'm not drinking because I sat down and did the math and then was like oh I don't know how to count life I I keep losing i can't count beyond three so who knows you know like it isn't that it's that this feels good i feel bad i come up with ways to feel good because that's what my
我不知道，也许在1955年是这样。但现在，我们都看过《黑道家族》。我们多少已经直觉地理解了CBT。我们多少已经直觉地理解了心理分析的刻板印象，可以说这就是心理分析。我们知道这些信息，我们只是需要我们的大脑感觉不同。你知道，我不是因为坐下来计算然后发现“哦，我不知道怎么算生活”才不喝酒的。我一直输，我数不到三，所以谁知道呢？你知道，不是那样，而是这感觉很好，我感觉很糟，我找到了让自己感觉良好的方法，因为这就是我的
brain is designed to do and like you know salt sugar fat dopamine um like yeah yeah we seek it out and and if if something gets in the way we find a way around it. So sorry, I didn't mean it. As you were talking to I was like, Oh, yeah, there's paragraph two of my psychology today profile, right? Because it's broken into these three main like sections is like, here's what I know to be true is that people want to be moderate drinkers, like that's kind of what they aspire to as the kind of gold standard for healthy. Right. But what I know to be true is that moderate drinkers do not actively
大脑被设计要做的事情。比如盐、糖、脂肪、多巴胺……是的，我们寻求它。如果有什么阻碍了我们，我们会找到绕过它的方法。抱歉，我不是那个意思。当你说话时，我在想：“哦，是的，这是我‘今日心理学’简介的第二段，对吧？”因为它分为这三个主要部分，就像：“我所知道的真相是，人们想成为适度饮酒者，这是他们渴望的健康金标准。”对吧。但我所知道的真相是，适度饮酒者并不会主动
moderate their drinking, which is to say it is an adjective to describe their behavior. It is not the verb they are using to acquire the behavior. They're not actively thinking, okay, so if I had someone, and if I know I have an event on Friday and I'm going to have four drinks and seven per week for women is kind of like the standard in the US, the guideline. So I'm not going to have drinks four days this week and then I'll have the four on Wednesday.
调节他们的饮酒量，也就是说，这是一个描述他们行为的形容词。这不是他们用来获得这种行为的动词。他们不会主动思考：“好吧，如果我有某人，如果我知道周五有个活动，我要喝四杯，而美国女性的标准是每周七杯。”所以我这周四天不喝，然后在周三喝那四杯。
Like people who are truly moderate drinkers, which is to say they just drink when they want to and only when they want to. And they never drink more than they want to. They're not actively doing that. It's like we're looking at this result and then trying to codify how to make that happen. Yeah, that's kind of my experience is that no one's actually doing the recommendation. They're just figuring out that they don't do the recommendation. And then saying, I guess I need to do the the recommendation but then when they do therapy they just stop most of the time or cut back to like christmas whiskey at christmas you know right i just don't know a ton of people who've come in and i mean i don't do what you do but i just don't know a ton
像那些真正适度饮酒的人，也就是他们只是在想喝的时候才喝，而且只在想喝的时候喝。他们从不喝得比他们想喝的多。他们不是在主动做这件事。就像我们看着这个结果，然后试图编纂如何实现它。是的，这就是我的经验，没有人真的在遵循建议。他们只是发现自己没有遵循建议。然后说：“我想我需要遵循那个建议。”但当他们进行治疗时，他们大多数时候就停止了，或者减少到像圣诞节喝点威士忌那样，对吧？我只是不知道有很多人进来……我的意思是，我不做你做的事，但我不知道有很多人
of people that are like yeah i'm drinking 30 beers a week. All right. Thank you. I got to three. That's fun. Like it just tends to just be something that you don't need or you move on from or something, you know, your relationship to it changes, which means that it's not where all of your intellectual energy is going. And that may not be your experience at all. Well, I just don't see a ton of people that are like, yep, I've had my seven for the week. Are you starting next? Like, it's just like, it's not coming up if you're not doing it no one's doing the fda recommendation well or or they are using
会说：“是的，我每周喝30瓶啤酒。”好吧，谢谢。我喝到三瓶了。那很有趣。它往往只是你不需要的东西，或者你从中走出来了，或者其他什么，你知道，你与它的关系改变了，这意味着它不再是你所有智力能量的去向。这可能根本不是你的经历。嗯，我只是没见过很多人会说：“是的，我这周喝了七杯。你下周开始吗？”就像，如果你没在做，它就不会出现。没有人遵循FDA的建议。好吧，或者他们
it as sort of a prison for themselves and then they feel like they are a crappy human being when that does that doesn't work for them like to just say and so what i find most of the people i work with um they are not going to seek out therapy for substance use issues because they don't really qualify for it, which quite honestly, yes, we've got the DSM and we've got substance use disorder, but this idea of alcoholic is a self-diagnostic term. And so there's this like fuzzy space of, well, do I talk like if I'm drinking the way the people around me are drinking, is that something I go to therapy for? And the answer is not really, which is why you're saying you don't see a lot of it, right? Like most of my people either are
把它当作自己的监狱，然后当它对他们不起作用时，他们觉得自己是个糟糕的人。所以，我发现我合作的大多数人，他们不会因为物质使用问题寻求治疗，因为他们真的不够格。说实话，是的，我们有DSM（精神疾病诊断与统计手册），我们有物质使用障碍，但“酒鬼”这个概念是一个自我诊断的术语。所以这里有一个模糊的空间：“如果我像周围的人一样喝酒，这是我需要去治疗的事情吗？”答案是不太需要，这就是为什么你说你没见过很多这种情况，对吧？我的人要么是
therapists or have been in therapy or are currently in therapy and they're in therapy to deal with the trauma and the relationships you know and then this drinking is kind of this side thing where maybe we ask about it at intake and we as professionals clock it as not you know substance use disorder and then it just kind of goes by the wayside yeah i don't have a drinking problem i have but my therapist keeps bringing up my drinking problem yes exactly exactly but so or even their therapist maybe drinks at the same level they do and it's like yeah that's fine because so for my people what i what i love is there's this spectrum out there that jolene park started and it's called or she didn't start it actually she popularized it kind of like made it more common vernacular is gray area drinking which is kind of like this drinking between the gray
治疗师，要么曾经接受过治疗，要么正在接受治疗，他们接受治疗是为了处理创伤和人际关系。你知道，然后这种饮酒只是一种副产品，也许我们在初诊时会问一下，我们作为专业人士将其标记为非物质使用障碍，然后它就随之而去了。是的，我没有饮酒问题，我有……但我的治疗师一直提起我的饮酒问题。是的，完全正确。所以，甚至他们的治疗师可能喝的量和他们一样，就像：“是的，那没关系。”所以对于我的人，我喜欢的是有一个光谱，乔琳·帕克（Jolene Park）发起的，它被称为……或者她其实没发起，她普及了它，让它成为更常见的词汇，即“灰色地带饮酒”，这就像是介于健康和滥用或成瘾之间的灰色地带。
area between healthy and and abuse or addicted when i like that because it isn't people calling addiction one thing like i just i see on linkedin and if you know uh not festivals what do you call conferences all the time like the the hardcore 12-step guys yelling at the non-12-step people about how both are wrong and I kind of disagree with both of them you know and but it's like you can admit that like addiction is a problem but not all addiction is the same yeah you know but it's that fight about like that all or nothing and I know that 12 step, you have to kind of buy into that in order to stay sober at the beginning. And some people need that. But then there's people that are angry that it's extrapolated to everybody in gray area drinking
我喜欢这个，因为它不是人们把成瘾称为一回事。我只是在领英上看到，如果你知道……不是节日，你称为什么？会议。一直有那些强硬的12步法支持者对非12步法的人大喊大叫，说双方都错了。我有点不同意他们俩。你知道，但就像你可以承认成瘾是一个问题，但并非所有成瘾都是一样的。是的，你知道，但那是关于非黑即白的争论。我知道12步法，你必须在开始时接受它才能保持清醒。有些人需要那个。但有些人很生气，因为它被推及到所有人身上。灰色地带饮酒
just seems a lot more general. Like I've never brought that up to somebody and have them be like, no, absolutely. I'm not a gray area drinker, you know? I think where it gets confusing though is, so now we can, you know, self-label as gray area drinkers. At what point then do we gauge, well, where is healthy gray area drinking and where's unhealthy? Well, it's gray. It's hard to say, right? So I have pulled out a subset of the people and these now are the people I work with. And then I work with a different group of people that we can get into. But as far as drinking habits and alcohol goes, there's this subset of people that I call Groundhog Day drinkers, which is they're in the gray area. So that's kind of part of it. But another way, another criteria that applies to
似乎更通用。我从来没向某人提起过这个，然后他们说：“不，绝对不是，我不是灰色地带饮酒者。”你知道吗？但我认为令人困惑的地方在于，现在我们可以（你知道）自我贴上灰色地带饮酒者的标签。那么在什么点上我们衡量“什么是健康的灰色地带饮酒，什么是病态的”？嗯，它是灰色的。很难说，对吧？所以我挑选了一部分人，这些人现在是我合作的对象。然后我与另一群人合作，我们可以深入探讨。但就饮酒习惯和酒精而言，有一部分人我称之为“土拨鼠日饮酒者”（Groundhog Day drinkers），也就是他们处于灰色地带。所以这是其中的一部分。但另一个适用于他们的标准是，
them, and there are three types of Groundhog Day drinkers. So I kind of have like a little, I actually have like a video I could share if anyone were listening, or like, oh my gosh, I need that video. Like they could just reach out to me and say, can you send me the types of Groundhog Day drinkers video and I'll send it. But when it's a Groundhog,
有三种类型的“土拨鼠日饮酒者”。所以我有一种……我其实有一个视频可以分享，如果有人在听的话，或者……天哪，我需要那个视频。他们可以直接联系我，说：“你能发给我‘土拨鼠日饮酒者’类型的视频吗？”我会发给他们。但当它是土拨鼠……
when you're a Groundhog Day drinker, it doesn't matter, it's not about amount or frequency. It doesn't matter how long ago or how recent your last drink was or how many you had it's that feeling of groundhog day which i love a good 90s rom-com and groundhog day is that 1993 bill murray andy mcdowell movie right they're still making them as a genre like i don't know have you seen little italy yes yes because it was like a jumping off platform for for just this idea yeah but i and i love it but so it's that idea i call them groundhog day
当你是一个“土拨鼠日饮酒者”时，这不重要，与数量或频率无关。无论你上次喝酒是多久以前或最近，或者你喝了多少，重要的是那种“土拨鼠日”的感觉。我喜欢90年代的浪漫喜剧，《土拨鼠日》是那部1993年比尔·默瑞和安迪·麦克道威尔的电影，对吧？他们还在把它们作为一种类型制作。我不知道，你看过《小意大利》吗？是的，是的，因为它就像一个跳板，为了这个概念。是的，但我喜欢它。所以我称他们为“土拨鼠日
drinkers because it's that idea of they have a drink however many they're gonna have whether it's a few or a lot or whatever but it's that next morning waking up and that repeated oh i just wish i hadn't had that one or had that last one or had those extra or gone to that event at all. It's that feeling of why can't I just stick to my goals? And that's what makes a Groundhog Day drinker. It's not about because for in I have been every type of Groundhog Day drinker. And actually, if, if we have time for a soapbox, I will climb on the soapbox about what we're getting taught about it is bass accords. But the thing is about all of them, it's not about how many you've had. If I had had one drink, I woke up thinking, God, why did I even have the one?
饮酒者”，因为这就是那种想法：他们喝了一杯，无论喝多少，无论是几杯还是很多，或者其他什么，但第二天早上醒来，那种重复的“哦，我真希望我没喝那杯，或者没喝最后那杯，或者没喝那些额外的，或者根本没去那个活动。”那种“为什么我就不能坚持我的目标？”的感觉。这就是让一个人成为“土拨鼠日饮酒者”的原因。这与……因为对于……我曾经是每一种类型的“土拨鼠日饮酒者”。而且实际上，如果我们有时间进行长篇大论，我会登上讲台，谈谈我们被教导的关于它的东西是……但关于所有这些，重点不在于你喝了多少。如果我喝了一杯，我醒来时想：“天哪，我为什么要喝那一杯？”
I just should have stuck with my zero. If I drank a bottle of wine, it was, God, why did I do that? I should have just stuck with the one I was gonna let myself have. But it's that repeated learning of whatever I did is not what I set out to do. And so that's why I call them Groundhog Day drinkers. And I think that gives this subset of the gray area population,
我本应该坚持我的零杯。如果我喝了一瓶酒，那是：“天哪，我为什么要那样做？我本应该坚持我本来打算喝的那一杯。”但这就是那种重复的学习：无论我做了什么，都不是我打算做的。这就是为什么我称他们为“土拨鼠日饮酒者”。我认为这给了灰色地带人群中的这一部分，
something a little more tangible to say, okay, so I'm in the gray area. How do I know if it needs addressing or not? Yeah. And so then how do you go about treating that if somebody comes in and that's their experience? Yeah. So I treat it using, I have a three pillar approach that I call the trifecta of change. Cause I love the word trifecta so much. It just feels good to me.
一些更具体的东西，说：“好吧，所以我处于灰色地带。我怎么知道它是否需要解决？”是的。那么，如果有人进来，而那是他们的经历，你如何去治疗它？是的。所以我用一种我称之为“改变的三重奏”（Trifecta of change）的三支柱方法来治疗它。因为我太喜欢“三重奏”这个词了。它让我感觉很好。
Does it mean it's like three things together, right? Yeah. Is it the same as triumvirate they're different is it i don't know because i know the word triumvirate i'm former english teacher by the way okay so like words are my thing i love it but i feel like i could go down a rabbit hole of where words are the same and are not the same and the what i love about trifecta is this idea of three things that come together and make something powerful. Um, and so in those three pillars, which kind of to answer your question of how, how do I treat it is we walk through these three pillars and part of the, the challenge is that the three pillars much like with trauma healing right are not a linear sequence where we don't go okay let's do pillar one for two weeks and then we're gonna do
它意味着三件事在一起，对吧？是的。它和“三头政治”（triumvirate）是一样的吗？它们不同。我不知道，因为我知道“三头政治”这个词，顺便说一下，我是前英语老师。好的，所以词汇是我的强项。我喜欢它，但我感觉我可以陷入一个关于哪些词是一样的、哪些是不一样的兔子洞。我喜欢“三重奏”的地方在于，这三件事结合在一起，产生强大的力量。嗯，在那些三个支柱中，为了回答你关于“如何”治疗的问题，我们走过这三个支柱。挑战的一部分是，这三个支柱就像创伤愈合一样，不是线性的顺序。我们不会说：“好吧，让我们做两周支柱一，然后我们要……”
pillar two they're not steps um having grown up in houston i always liken it to you know hurricanes would come through and we get all of these floods and then people would raise their houses and start to put pillars under the houses and you don't just like jack up one corner of the house and you have to do and then jack yeah you have to do a little bit and then go around and a little bit more to each pillar and then go and add a little more to each pillar so the whole thing slowly rises so part of treating it is figuring out how the nuances of how to add which pillar at which time, because Groundhog Day drinkers are all different, right? So you're saying that instead of doing steps like a hierarchy,
支柱二，它们不是步骤。在休斯顿长大，我总是把它比作……你知道飓风会经过，我们会有所有的洪水，然后人们会抬高他们的房子，开始在房子下面放柱子。你不会只是把房子的一角顶起来，你必须……是的，你必须做一点，然后绕过去，给每个支柱多加一点，然后再去给每个支柱多加一点，这样整个东西就会慢慢升起。所以治疗的一部分是弄清楚如何添加支柱的细微差别，在什么时候添加，因为“土拨鼠日饮酒者”各不相同，对吧？所以你是说，与其像等级制度那样做步骤，
being able to do multiple things at once has a synergistic effect where they are all stronger. Yes, thank you for saying that in such a succinct way for me. I think I answered my question too in that like the triumvirate implies limitation on three, on power, like Rome. Yeah. And Trispecta is the synergistic effect making them all stronger. So I was curious. So everyone go take your SATs now and score high on the English because those words will be on there. Can you go through like what some of those steps are, how you work, frame it, where brain spotting comes into that, you know, whatever you feel like is helpful? Absolutely. Oh yeah. Tell me when to stop. Just cut me off when you need to.
能够同时做多件事会产生协同效应，使它们都更强大。是的，谢谢你用如此简洁的方式为我表达出来。我想我也回答了自己的问题，即“三头政治”暗示了对权力的限制，就像罗马那样。是的。而“三重奏”是协同效应，使它们都更强大。所以我很好奇。所以大家现在去参加SAT考试吧，在英语上拿高分，因为那些词会出现在上面。你能简单介绍一下那些步骤是什么，你是如何工作的，构建它，脑点定位在其中处于什么位置，你知道，任何你觉得有帮助的东西？当然。哦，是的。告诉我什么时候停。需要的时候就打断我。
I have my tea here that I'm drinking for the non-drinking episode. There you go. I've got my water. Oh yeah. It's a non-drinking episode. There you go. I never drink. Oh, okay. So the different pillars. So the first pillar and because there does have to be a first, like you have to start somewhere, even though it is really synergistic. The first one is the first one because it's the easiest to put in place and does not have brain spotting in it yet
我这儿有茶，我正在为这个“不饮酒”的剧集喝茶。给你。我有我的水。哦，是的。这是一个不饮酒的剧集。给你。我从不喝酒。哦，好的。所以不同的支柱。所以第一个支柱，因为确实必须有一个第一，就像你必须从某处开始，尽管它确实非常协同。第一个是第一个，因为它是最容易实施的，而且里面还没有脑点定位，
um and it's just what i call uh oh it's the personalized daily support plan which for most people who so let's just stick with and i don't know when this episode is going to get published but we're recording at a time where the holidays are about to hit in the u.s and um you know new year's eve is coming up, New Year's resolutions, which historically for the Groundhog Day drinking community. Politics is coming up around the dinner table. Politics is also coming up. But also the idea of dry January is real big in the Groundhog Day drinking community. And so what happens with dry January is everyone approaches it like this.
嗯，这只是我所说的……哦，这是“个性化日常支持计划”。对于大多数人来说……所以让我们坚持……我不知道这一集什么时候发布，但我们录制的时候，美国假期快到了，嗯，你知道，新年前夜快到了，新年决心，这在历史上对于“土拨鼠日饮酒”社区来说是……政治话题也快出现在餐桌上了。政治也快出现了。但“干一月”（Dry January）的想法在“土拨鼠日饮酒”社区里非常流行。所以“干一月”发生的事情是，每个人都这样处理：
Let's just take a break. Let's just take a break from alcohol. It's a 30 day break, a reset. And oh gosh, I'm about to mix my metaphors. Let me get back on. We'll get to that one in a minute. So what happens is people start to share strategies, right? And they'll say things like, yeah, like if I want to drink, I'm just going to go for a walk. And then a Groundhog Day drinker will say, okay, well then this works for all of these people. They just take a break. They just cut it out for 30 days. And if they want to drink, they just go for a walk. And then when that person goes for a walk and then still pours a glass of wine, they think they're the problem
“让我们休息一下。让我们从酒精中休息一下。这是一个30天的休息，一个重置。”哦，天哪，我快要混淆我的隐喻了。让我回到正题。我们一会儿再谈那个。所以发生的事情是人们开始分享策略，对吧？他们会说：“是的，如果我想喝酒，我就去散步。”然后一个“土拨鼠日饮酒者”会说：“好吧，那么这对所有这些人都有用。他们只是休息一下。他们只是断掉30天。如果他们想喝酒，他们就去散步。”然后当那个人去散步，然后仍然倒了一杯酒时，他们认为自己是问题所在，
when really the walk wasn't the daily support they needed. So we have to personalize the daily support, which is true for all of our clients, right? Like, you know, even up to, you know, very, very complex, extremely complex PTSD, right? Like we need to personalize how we're self soothing. And so that's the first pillar is, I call it a values based nurture plan where we it's almost like an acceptance and commitment therapy type activity where we really hone down what are the person's values and how do we build a support program out of their unique values? And what I think is great about that is that I've never seen two people have the exact same set. Like it just
而实际上散步并不是他们需要的日常支持。所以我们必须个性化日常支持，这对我们所有的客户都是真实的，对吧？比如，你知道，甚至到……非常、非常复杂，极其复杂的PTSD，对吧？我们需要个性化我们如何自我安抚。所以这是第一个支柱，我称之为“基于价值的培育计划”，我们……这几乎就像一种“接纳与承诺疗法”（ACT）类型的活动，我们真正磨练出个人的价值观是什么，以及我们如何根据他们独特的价值观建立一个支持计划？我认为这很棒的地方在于，我从未见过两个人有完全相同的组合。它只是……
is, it's a really easy way to individualize. So that's the first pillar we put in because it is the easiest and the fastest to put it. Um, as we get our value-based nurture plan, and then we talk about, okay, what does it look like to implement this plan? And then we build in the supports for implementing it. Um, the second pillar of the trifecta is the subcortical change, which is just straight. This is where we learn how to do brain spotting and my clients because we're not working on clinical things um they'll do they have the option to brain spot with me in a group which we'll do every couple of weeks and i'm giving them guided audios and um kind of a calendar a customizable calendar if they do this self brain spotting exercise x number of times so it's a very like self-paced it's like
这是一种非常简单的个体化方式。所以这是我们放入的第一个支柱，因为它是最容易、最快放入的。嗯，当我们得到我们的基于价值的培育计划后，我们谈论：“好吧，实施这个计划是什么样的？”然后我们建立实施它的支持。嗯，第二个支柱是“皮层下改变”，这只是直接的。这是我们学习如何做脑点定位的地方。我的客户，因为我们不是在处理临床问题，他们可以选择在小组中与我进行脑点定位，我们每隔几周做一次，我给他们指导音频，嗯，一种日历，一个可定制的日历，如果他们做这个自我脑点定位练习X次……所以它非常像……自定进度，它就像
a free spotting type exercise or something um no because i am still using four sometimes five depending on the person really specific setups for it um but we are always coming at it more i say always but you know nothing's ever certain in brain spotting we are attempting most of the time to come at it from a resource place because it is self-led brain spotting not clinician-led brain spotting um so we bring that piece in they learn the different the different setups they do the guided audios it's almost like if you think about um you know a lot of people ask me well I don't want to go to meetings. Like I don't I don't meetings are not what do it for me. And I'm like, yeah, no, I don't want to go to meetings either.
一种自由定位类型的练习或其他什么……嗯，不，因为我仍然在使用四种，有时五种（取决于人）非常具体的设置。但我们总是更多地从资源角度出发……我说是总是，但你知道，脑点定位中没有什么是确定的。我们大多数时候试图从资源角度出发，因为它是自我引导的脑点定位，而不是临床医生引导的脑点定位。所以我们引入那部分，他们学习不同的设置，他们做指导音频。这几乎就像如果你考虑……嗯，你知道，很多人问我：“嗯，我不想去参加会议。”就像，我不……会议不是对我起作用的东西。我说：“是的，不，我也不想去参加会议。”
I also don't want to leave. So I liken it more to a group workout class, like a group fitness class where you don't go in it, like at the beginning, you talk to people, because maybe you know them, because you see them there all the time, because you've all got like class pass, and you're, you know, at the same classes all the time. But you're not then telling them, here's what the workout was like for me. Oh, I went, you know, I was gonna order a cheeseburger last night, like, you're not really sharing all of that. You're just going in, kind of maybe talking about, okay, today, the goal is legs, we're all going to work on our legs, right? So maybe they going in, kind of maybe talking about, okay, today the goal is legs. We're all going to work on our legs, right? So maybe they come in and I say, okay, today the goal is
我也不想离开。所以我把它比作一个小组锻炼课，就像一个小组健身课，你进去的时候，在开始时，你和人们交谈，因为也许你认识他们，因为你一直看到他们在那儿，因为你们都有像“ClassPass”那样的东西，而且你，你知道，一直都在同样的课上。但你并没有告诉他们：“我昨晚的锻炼感觉如何。哦，我去了，你知道，我昨晚本来要点一个芝士汉堡……”就像，你并没有真正分享所有这些。你只是进去，可能谈论：“好吧，今天，目标是腿，我们都要锻炼我们的腿，对吧？”所以也许他们进去，可能谈论：“好吧，今天目标是腿。我们都要锻炼我们的腿，对吧？”所以也许他们进来，我说：“好吧，今天目标是
we're going to do the crocodile setup. So we're all working on creating one synergized story around alcohol and then we do it. So it's more like a workout class for your brain than it is like a meeting per se does that make sense yeah i've i've heard that there's some places i don't think there's one in birmingham but i've heard from some people that live in other cities that there's like basically like moderation groups where they just like get around and talk about moderation and kind of health and probably have accountability without total sobriety yeah i'm sure mean, that's kind of the beauty of the gray area, right? And the beauty of the ever-connected age we live in, right?
我们要进行鳄鱼设置。”所以我们都在致力于围绕酒精创造一个协同的故事，然后我们做它。所以它更像是一个为你大脑准备的锻炼课，而不是像一个会议。这有意义吗？是的，我听说有些地方……我不认为伯明翰有一个，但我从一些住在其他城市的人那里听说，有类似“适度小组”的东西，他们只是聚在一起谈论适度，谈论健康，可能在没有完全清醒的情况下有问责制。是的，我确定……我的意思是，这就是灰色地带的美妙之处，对吧？以及我们生活在这个互联时代的美妙之处，对吧？
Which is you can jump online and find a community that matches what you're looking for. And I think that's what's unique about my community of people too, is while I don't work solely with entrepreneurs, I do work a lot with entrepreneurs. And it's that mindset of, I want to get out of this unhealthy relationship with alcohol, not because I want to, you know, necessarily have stellar health, or I want to, you know, beat an addiction, which is true for some of my people but the vast majority are people who like they're just too effing busy trying to run a business to be held back by the ankle weight of alcohol they're those like nobody's got time and energy for that they've got bigger things they
你可以上网找到一个符合你所寻找的社区。我认为这也是我的社区独特的地方，虽然我不只与企业家合作，但我确实与很多企业家合作。这是一种心态：“我想摆脱这种不健康的酒精关系，不是因为我想，你知道，一定要有极好的健康，或者我想，你知道，战胜成瘾（这对一些人来说是真的），但绝大多数人是那些……他们太忙了，忙着经营生意，不能被酒精的脚镣拖累。”他们是那些……没有人有时间和精力去处理那个，他们有更大的事情
need to be accomplishing so when you get people to realize how much time it actually is taking up because it's like oh yeah okay. Okay. There's a mistake, whatever. And you realize like, okay, you slept till this time. And then the rest of the day was still kind of a waste because you're not firing on all cylinders and now you're behind for the week and now your
需要完成。所以当你让人们意识到它实际上占用了多少时间，因为它就像：“哦，是的，好吧。好吧。有一个错误，无论什么。”当你意识到：“好吧，你睡到了这个时候。然后剩下的一天仍然是一种浪费，因为你没有全力以赴，现在你这周落后了，现在你的
sleep's behind. So you're tired, you know, like it just, and I, like, I think too, like for people in the gray area,
睡眠落后了。”所以你很累，你知道，就像它只是……而且我，就像，我也认为，对于灰色地带的人来说，
like, like tiredness becomes a trigger, but then alcohol makes you tire a trigger but then alcohol makes you tireder but then it makes you wake up a little bit while you're drinking it but then it still makes your quality of sleep terrible and it becomes this vicious thing and i don't know if you like go into like a lot of the psychoeducation about like the the way that it works in the brain but i think that's one of the nefarious things about it and why it's one of those drugs that's like allowed you know quote unquote where a lot of them are not is that
就像……疲劳成为了一种触发因素，但酒精让你更累……触发因素，但酒精让你更累，但它让你在喝的时候清醒了一点，但它仍然让你的睡眠质量变得糟糕，它变成了一种恶性循环。我不知道你是否会深入探讨关于它在大脑中运作方式的心理教育，但我认为这是它最邪恶的事情之一，也是为什么它是那种“被允许的”（引用引号）药物，而很多其他药物不是，因为
it's a stimulant antidepressant in different parts of the brain at the same time yeah and so you're kind of addicted to one half of it and then the other one is a problem you know some of this yeah well and perfect segue thank you into the third pillar which is I vacillate kind of between, or oscillate, I'm getting in my head about more words now, between informed decision making and embodied decision making, because the pillar is the same either way. But it's that idea of first, we got to know these things, right? Like, if I'm having a glass of wine at night or a glass of whiskey at night, because I think it helps me sleep, well, I need to get some updated information on that. Right. Um, but the problem that most of my groundhog day drinkers have is that knowing it is insufficient. And that's why we have this groundhog day phenomenon, because as you and I know, like we learn in this one part of our brain and we you know that information is stored in a different part than this like intrinsic drive and even just to go back to and i don't know if you have more
它同时是大脑不同部分的兴奋剂和抗抑郁药。是的，所以你有点对它的一半上瘾，然后另一半是个问题。你知道其中一些……是的，嗯，完美的过渡，谢谢你进入第三个支柱，我有点在……或者振荡，我现在在脑子里想更多的词，在“知情决策”和“具身决策”之间，因为支柱无论如何都是一样的。但这是一种想法：首先，我们必须知道这些事情，对吧？比如，如果我晚上喝一杯酒或一杯威士忌，因为我认为它能帮助我睡眠，嗯，我需要获得一些关于此的更新信息。对吧。嗯，但我大多数“土拨鼠日饮酒者”的问题是，知道它是不够的。这就是为什么我们有这种“土拨鼠日”现象，因为正如你和我所知，就像我们在大脑的这一部分学习，我们……你知道，信息存储在与这种内在驱动力不同的部分。甚至只是回到……我不知道你是否有更多
updated stats on this but like how the decision making time or the action time between the subcortical and the neocort or the prefrontal cortex where like subcortical is moving or amygdala i guess is moving at like 0.03 milliseconds which i guess is like or 0.03 seconds which i guess is like 30 milliseconds versus 0.7 seconds for the top which is like 23 times as slow i mean it's lightning fast in the difference but that's 23 times as slow, right? And so what I'll tell people is that's why alcohol, the way you're describing it too, with this, like the vicious nefarious cycle of sleep, is it's like an ankle weight, right? Like,
关于这个的更新统计数据，但比如皮层下和新皮层或前额叶皮层之间的决策时间或行动时间，比如皮层下正在移动，或者杏仁核，我想是在以0.03毫秒的速度移动，我想这就像……或者0.03秒，我想这就像30毫秒，而顶部是0.7秒，这慢了23倍。我的意思是，差异是闪电般的速度，但那是慢了23倍，对吧？所以我告诉人们的是，这就是为什么酒精，正如你所描述的那样，伴随着这种……睡眠的恶性邪恶循环，它就像一个脚镣，对吧？就像，
we put two to five pound weights on our ankles, and we can walk around for, you know, 10 minutes, 23 times that, 230 minutes, you may start to notice it. Maybe you wear it for an hour, try it for 23 hours. It's gonna be a noticeable difference. But it eats away very slowly when we're Groundhog Day drinkers versus full-on high-level substance use disorder.
我们在脚踝上放两到五磅的重物，我们可以走动，你知道，10分钟，23倍，230分钟，你可能会开始注意到它。也许你戴了一个小时，试着戴23个小时。那将是一个明显的差异。但当我们是“土拨鼠日饮酒者”时，它会非常缓慢地侵蚀，而不是完全的高水平物质使用障碍。
The impact is just a lot. I mean, nefarious really is the right word, right? Because it's so subtle, but it's compounding. And so that's why the third pillar is because is the informed decision making and embodied decision making, because we need to learn that information. And then we need that information. So we talked earlier, and I know you and I talked kind of pre-podcast about this on our phone call about the idea of like the one continuous story and you know like that being like a solid way to describe it but not really sure scientifically how that's working out um
影响很大。我的意思是，“邪恶”确实是正确的词，对吧？因为它太微妙了，但它在复合。所以这就是为什么第三个支柱是“知情决策”和“具身决策”，因为我们需要学习那些信息。然后我们需要那些信息。所以我们之前谈过，我知道你和我之前在电话里谈过关于“一个连续的故事”的想法，你知道，那是一个描述它的可靠方式，但不太确定科学上它是如何运作的……
other than neurons that fire together wire together but that third piece being well how do i embody information and it's that difference between knowing something and like knowing yeah and so that's the third pillar is take first of all let's get some stuff and let's know it but then let's like know it so that you act from that knowledge not just beat yourself up with the knowledge like a guilt stick later on groundhog day. I think it's that like intellectual memory is tied to like referencing the future and referencing the past, but it doesn't affect me right now. You know, it's like, I'm going to drink right now so that I don't drink later on. And then that way I'll get it out of the way or whatever, you know, like, but it's not
除了“一起激发的神经元连接在一起”，但那第三部分是……好吧，我如何体现信息？这就是“知道某事”和“知道”之间的区别。是的，所以第三个支柱是……首先，让我们得到一些东西，让我们知道它，但然后让我们……体现它，这样你就根据那种知识行动，而不是像以后的“土拨鼠日”那样用知识鞭打自己，像一根内疚棍。我认为这就像智力记忆与引用未来和引用过去有关，但它现在对我没有影响。你知道，就像：“我现在要喝酒，这样我以后就不会喝了。”然后那样我就能把它处理掉，或者其他什么，你知道，但它不是
feeling it's, it's not felt or experiential. It's not embodied. Exactly. It's, it's a memory or experiential. It's not embodied. It's a memory that we're kind of referencing about something that isn't my behavior right now. But, you know, everybody who has their last cigarette for, you know, five years or something. Yeah. Yeah, exactly. And very similarly, how right now me that's waking up saying I'm never going gonna drink again is not the same me that's like
感觉……它不是被感受到的或经验性的。它不是具身的。完全正确。它……它是一种记忆或经验性的。它不是具身的。它是一种记忆，我们正在引用关于某种不是我现在的行为的东西。但是，你知道，每个有最后一支烟的人，你知道，五年左右什么的。是的。是的，完全一样。而且非常相似，现在的我醒来说“我再也不喝酒了”并不是那个……的同一个我。
at this level of drinking people aren't crawling out of bed and pouring a drink so it's it's not happening at the same time they're not even wanting a drink until hours later when they've you know been fighting with the kids all day and running their business all day and are trying to finally settle down and quiet their business running brain, which, you know, you as a business owner know, like that's a tall order to not take work home with you when you are so actively involved in a business, right? Like it's very different than being an employee. And so then because there's such a huge time delay in those two experiences, like you said, that information is not accessible in that moment. Yeah. It appears to be irrelevant in that moment, even though it's as relevant as anything else in the world could be.
在这个饮酒水平下，人们不会从床上爬起来倒酒喝，所以这并不是同时发生的。他们甚至在几个小时后才想喝酒，那时他们可能已经和孩子们吵了一整天，忙了一整天生意，终于想静下心来，让忙碌的大脑安静下来。你知道，作为企业主，你很清楚，当你如此积极地参与生意时，不把工作带回家是一项艰巨的任务，对吧？这和作为一名员工是非常不同的。所以，因为这两种体验之间存在巨大的时间延迟，正如你所说，那些信息在当下是无法获取的。是的，在那个时刻，它看起来似乎无关紧要，尽管它可能和世界上任何其他事情一样重要。
Well, it's not me and my reality that I'm thinking about. It's what I did before that I feel bad about and what I'm going to do different tomorrow. But it's not what I'm doing. Right, right, right. right yeah so those are the three pillars that's how we end so we we do a little bit at a time on each one weave them all together and snap crackle pop the trifecta and you do a lot of other stuff too i mean you don't just see people who are doing gray area drinking i mean you do kind of coaching with other, um, with other people or other types of issues. I do. Yeah, I do. Um, my second biggest part of what I would call a caseload, which is not, I mean, I guess anyone can call it a caseload, right? Like I'm like, not to sound
嗯，我思考的不是我和我的现实。而是我之前做过的事情，我为此感到难过，以及我明天打算做些什么不同的事情。但这并不是我正在做的事情。对，对，对。没错，是的，这就是那三个支柱，这就是我们结束的方式，所以我们每次做一点，把它们编织在一起，然后啪的一声，三连胜。你还做了很多其他事情，我的意思是，你不仅仅是看那些有灰色地带饮酒问题的人，我的意思是，你还对其他人，或者其他类型的问题进行辅导。是的，我确实做。嗯，我所谓的案例量中第二大的部分，这并不是，我的意思是，我想任何人都可以称之为案例量，对吧？就像我，不是为了听起来
clinical is, um, just really high performing folks who are dealing. So when I was practicing under my license, my specialties were anxiety and obsessive compulsive disorder. So now I've just kind of taken that a few notches down and I'm working still with business owners at this point. Now they are not drinking because that's kind of like the order of operations or I say not drinking. They're no longer concerned about their relationship with alcohol. They're at a healthy level and it matches what they want. And they're no longer actively moderating. They're just either drinking or not drinking at what is- They're doing what they want and that's lining up with what they want to do. Yes. Yes. Thank you. And so then we work on things like people pleasing, healthy boundaries,
临床上，嗯，真的就是那些正在应对问题的高绩效人士。所以当我还在执照下执业时，我的专长是焦虑症和强迫症。所以现在我只是把那个标准稍微降低了一点，目前我仍然在和企业主一起工作。现在他们不喝酒了，因为那就像是操作顺序，或者我说不喝酒。他们不再关心自己与酒精的关系。他们处于一个健康的水平，这符合他们的意愿。他们不再积极地进行节制。他们只是在喝酒或不喝酒，处于什么状态——他们在做他们想做的事，这与他们想做的事情是一致的。是的。是的。谢谢。所以我们处理像讨好型人格、健康的界限这样的事情，
a lot of attachment stuff, but again, not the trauma end of it, which is hard. It's a fine line to walk, right? And I know there are a lot of coaches out there who don't take that line very seriously. And they'll end up doing trauma work, even not as a licensed clinician. I have a huge, you know, soapbox about that. I think if you're going to be doing that level of work you need to be working with someone who is following all of the ethical and state licensing things in your area but it is an important line but it is kind of a great one you know it's like trauma sort of in everything but when you're really digging into something you know how deep can i go you understand what
很多依恋方面的问题，但同样，不是创伤那一端，这很难。这是一条很难走的细线，对吧？我知道有很多教练并不太认真对待这条界限。他们最终会进行创伤工作，即使他们不是持证临床医生。我对此有一个很大的，你知道，高谈阔论。我认为如果你要进行那种水平的工作，你需要和那些遵循你所在地区所有道德和州许可规定的人一起工作，但这确实是一条重要的界限，但它确实有点模糊，你知道，就像创伤在某种程度上存在于一切事物中，但当你真正深入挖掘某件事时，你知道我能走多深？你明白什么
people get lost but yeah you do here are some coaches on instagram something, you know, how deep can I go? And you understand what people get lost, but yeah, you do. Here are some coaches on Instagram talking about, you know, stuff when it's like, well, you know, what are you, what are you doing? It gets a little cringy and, um, Well, and then the crystal starts coming out and the yoga starts coming out. That does, that's where I'm really, that's where I get really nervous is that it's like, you know, I got a lot of crystals in my office, but you know, they're not medical interventions, you know?
人们会迷失，但是的，你确实会。在Instagram上有一些教练，你知道，我能走多深？你明白人们会迷失，但是的，你确实会。在Instagram上有一些教练在谈论，你知道，当事情是，嗯，你知道，你在做什么？这变得有点令人尴尬，而且，嗯，好吧，然后水晶开始拿出来了，瑜伽也开始拿出来了。确实，这就是我真正感到紧张的地方，就是，你知道，我的办公室里有很多水晶，但你知道，它们不是医疗干预措施，你知道吗？
Well, and I, you know, and I love all, I support all forms, whatever works for whatever person, but if we're going to be talking trauma, it needs to be someone with some sort of license. Just because there's a governing body and there, and there are repercussions for the person if harm does come out of it, right? Like if you're working with a coach, you don't really have a lot of repercussions. Well, you're bound by the laws that the person who receives the service has active in their state. And you don't know the laws of 50 states a lot of the time. So if I get online and I say that I'm a therapist and you receive services to me as a therapist, and that's a regulated term in your state.
嗯，而且我，你知道，我喜欢所有，我支持所有形式，无论对什么人有效，但如果我们谈论创伤，它需要是一个有某种执照的人。仅仅因为有一个管理机构，而且如果真的造成了伤害，对那个人会有后果，对吧？就像如果你和一个教练一起工作，你真的没有太多的后果。嗯，你受到服务接受者在他们州内有效的法律的约束。而且你很多时候并不知道50个州的法律。所以如果我上网说我是一名治疗师，而你作为治疗师接受了我的服务，那在你所在的州是一个受监管的术语。
I mean, I think hypnosis is only regulated in all, but three, it's only three states, but I mean, depending on the intervention you're doing, you can't say you do it without a certain kind of license. And you look at the internet, it's the wild west. Nobody even knows the laws that they're breaking. Exactly. Well, exactly. Which means you don't, I mean,
我的意思是，我认为催眠术只在所有州中的三个州受到监管，但我的意思是，根据你正在做的干预措施，如果没有某种执照，你不能说你做了它。你看看互联网，那是狂野的西部。甚至没有人知道他们正在违反的法律。完全正确。嗯，完全正确。这意味着你没有，我的意思是，
when I used to do liability training with churches would go in and be like, this is why you have to have the window here and whatever. And somebody be like, but what if somebody asked him to be like, stop, look in my eyes, pretend I'm on a jury, say what you're going to say. And then they would be like, sit down. And I mean, like that, that's my line is with clinicians at Taproot is like, imagine what you're writing is being read in court would you still write that thing yeah and we say that with my group of friends that are all therapists too but um i guess kind of what i was getting at is so with that in my background and doing the work i do as a coach we may not be coming in for that but i am more than equipped to handle and recognize if and when it comes up to where it's not like i don't have to put the brakes on and be like stop we have entered trauma area i cannot do this right like i can continue to hold that space and let that process complete and then say listen as a licensed clinician and not working with you under that license what i know is that was a clinical something and not working with you under that license, what I know is that
当我过去在教堂做责任培训时，我会进去说，这就是为什么你必须在这里有窗户等等。然后有人会说，但如果有人让他说，停下，看着我的眼睛，假装我在陪审团上，说你要说的话。然后他们会说，坐下。我的意思是，这就是我的底线，对于Taproot的临床医生来说，就像是，想象一下你写的东西正在法庭上被宣读，你还会写那个东西吗？是的，我和我的朋友们也经常这样说，他们也都是治疗师，但是，嗯，我想我想要表达的是，所以有了我的背景，并且作为一名教练做我所做的工作，我们可能不是为了那个而来，但我完全有能力处理并识别它是否以及何时出现，以至于我不必踩刹车说，停，我们已经进入了创伤区域，我不能这样做，对吧？我可以继续保持那个空间，让那个过程完成，然后说，听着，作为一名持证临床医生，而不是以那个执照与你一起工作，我知道那是一个临床上的什么，而不是以那个执照与你一起工作，我知道的是
was a clinical something, and then I can help them find the appropriate resources. So it's a piece of A, recognizing that it's out of the scope of what I'm practicing right now, and B, still being able to hold that as it comes up and not having it. Because I think it can be really harmful if it comes up with someone, let's say as someone is not licensed and i'm not trying to knock other coaches by any stretch of the imagination but like you said the internet is the wild west right like and so well i mean a lot of the people saying that they do coaching are not even licensed as coaches you know but there is no license i mean there's no governing body for it like even like i have a coaching certification but it's because someone
那是一个临床上的什么，然后我可以帮助他们找到适当的资源。所以这是A的一部分，认识到它超出了我目前执业的范围，以及B，仍然能够在它出现时保持它，而不是让它发生。因为我认为如果它出现在某人身上，比如说某人没有执照，这可能会非常有害，我绝不是想贬低其他教练，但就像你说的，互联网是狂野的西部，对吧？所以，嗯，我的意思是，很多说他们做教练的人甚至没有作为教练的执照，你知道吗？但没有执照，我的意思是，没有管理机构，就像我有一个教练认证，但那是因为有人
decided to make a coaching certification right like there's not a state or national board that's over what you're doing nope and there's no ethics committee but i just mean there's people that are saying like i'm a coach that decided that that was what they were going to call themselves yesterday yeah it's a self-diagnostic label as well yeah um but so even let's say even if a coach is really you know all about best practices and he and helping people heal and will recognize oh trauma you know came out they still might not be able to handle a person in that state and they may do more harm even with the best of intentions. Right.
决定制作一个教练认证，对吧？没有一个州或国家委员会来监督你正在做的事情，没有，而且没有道德委员会，但我只是说有些人说，我是教练，昨天决定这就是他们要称呼自己的名字，是的，这也是一个自我诊断的标签，是的，嗯，但所以即使，假设即使一个教练真的，你知道，非常注重最佳实践，并且帮助人们治愈，并且会识别出，哦，创伤，你知道，出现了，他们仍然可能无法处理处于那种状态的人，即使是出于最好的意图，他们也可能造成更大的伤害。对。
So I think it's, I think it's when you're not there, you don't, you don't know what happens when the person gets off. You may never see him again because you're doing teletherapy, you know? So it's right. Well, not teletherapy, telecoaching. Yeah. Telecoaching. Yeah.
所以我认为，我认为当你不在那里时，你不知道当那个人离开时会发生什么。你可能再也见不到他了，因为你在做远程治疗，你知道吗？所以这是对的。嗯，不是远程治疗，是远程教练。是的。远程教练。是的。
Tell us something, you know? Yeah. Tell us something. But yeah, so it is, I mean, there's just a lot of nuance to the work so all that to say the other people i work with tend to be um really high performing people pleasing mostly business owners we do a lot of brain spotting around perfectionism healthy boundaries money shit can i cuss on your podcast oh yeah please okay money money shit i just feel like there's enough podcasts out there. I mean, I'm not going out of my way to be offensive or something,
告诉我们一些事情，你知道吗？是的。告诉我们一些事情。但是是的，所以它是，我的意思是，这项工作有很多细微差别，所以所有这些都是为了说，我一起工作的其他人往往是，嗯，真正的高绩效、讨好型人格，主要是企业主，我们围绕完美主义、健康的界限、金钱破事做了很多大脑定位，我可以在你的播客上骂人吗？哦，是的，请便，好的，金钱，金钱破事，我只是觉得外面有足够的播客了。我的意思是，我并不是故意要冒犯什么，或者什么的，
but I also have just had an ax to grind for a long time that I feel like mysticism and psychology can be, like, funny because it is hysterical. Oh, it's hilarious. Yeah, they've shipped all of these podcasts where they're like, here's the 10 tips to stay healthy in spring by eating broccoli. And you're just like, I don't want another one of those podcasts. Like, I think that like, you know, or even the Jungian people, which are some of the, you know, cooler therapists, some of the time, it's like the, you know, the, the, the, I think one of the reasons this Jungian life was so successful is just because they spoke English. I mean, where you had like other people, and then they're just like the power of
但我也有一个长期以来的不满，我觉得神秘主义和心理学可以是，就像，很有趣，因为它歇斯底里。哦，这太搞笑了。是的，他们运送了所有这些播客，他们就像，这是春天保持健康的10个秘诀，通过吃西兰花。你只是觉得，我不想再听那样的播客了。就像，我认为，你知道，或者甚至是荣格学派的人，他们是，你知道，更酷的治疗师，有时，就像，你知道，那个，那个，那个，我认为《This Jungian Life》之所以如此成功，仅仅是因为他们说的是英语。我的意思是，你有像其他人一样，然后他们只是像力量
the archetype is so strong you have to be careful it's like your office isn't a strip ball man come on like i think what happens too even just from a marketing perspective is that there are people who then aren't going to come in because they don't have that like chilled out like zenned out vibe where that speaks to them right so they do need to be more of us who are like anyways this shit is freaking nuts right i feel like it's hard for business owners to find therapy sometimes because a lot of times the therapists are like threatened by it or something you know like there's like they view it as like i don't know what the word for it you know what i mean you you see that energy come up i mean mean, because I, like, I've done this.
原型太强大了，你必须小心，就像你的办公室不是脱衣舞俱乐部，伙计，拜托，就像我认为发生的事情，即使只是从营销的角度来看，也有一些人因为没有那种放松的、禅意的氛围而不会进来，因为那对他们来说是有意义的，对吧？所以确实需要更多像我们这样的人，他们会说，无论如何，这破事真是疯了，对吧？我觉得企业主有时很难找到治疗，因为很多时候治疗师会被它威胁，或者什么的，你知道，就像他们把它视为，我不知道怎么形容，你知道我的意思吗？你看到那种能量出现，我的意思是，因为我，就像，我做过这个。
It's a power differential, a power dynamic. Yeah. That a therapist needs to address in their own therapy. Yeah. Yeah. Well, I mean, that, again. And I don't know that it's, like, getting it done and leveling up. I think it's knowing that you're not done is the thing.
这是一种权力差异，一种权力动态。是的。治疗师需要在他们自己的治疗中解决这个问题。是的。是的。嗯，我的意思是，那，再次。而且我不知道这是否像，完成它并升级。我认为知道你还没有完成才是关键。
You know, like, I know where the shadow is in the room because I'll tell you. Like, you know, it's the person that's like, oh, no, I did CBD for six years. I'm all better. You know, that's, you don't know where the shadow is in the room because i'll tell you like you know it's the person that's like oh no i i did cbt for six years i'm all better you know that's you don't know where that's and i think too like how beautifully and i when i found the brain spotting community i was like these are my freaking people like oh yeah And I think that the uncertainty principle is part of what makes it my people because I have an absolute love-hate relationship with uncertainty. I worked with anxiety and OCD because those are experiences that I can really connect with and that just like need to latch on and feel a sense of certainty and a sense of control over things I have no control over and how healing is not how do I find better ways to control it, but is rather how do I release control, which is now we got to talk quietly about our crystals and releasing control. But at the end of the day, that's what it really is. And so the uncertainty principle was a
你知道，就像，我知道阴影在房间里的什么地方，因为我会告诉你。就像，你知道，就是那个人说，哦，不，我做了六年的CBT。我全好了。你知道，那，你不知道阴影在房间里的什么地方，因为我会告诉你，就像，你知道，就是那个人说，哦，不，我做了六年的CBT。我全好了。你知道，那，你不知道那在哪里，而且我也认为，就像多么美妙，当我发现大脑定位社区时，我就想，这些人就是我的人，就像，哦，是的，而且我认为不确定性原则是我的人的一部分，因为我对不确定性有一种绝对的爱恨交织的关系。我从事焦虑症和强迫症的工作，因为那些是我真正能产生共鸣的体验，而且就像需要依附并对那些我无法控制的事情感到一种确定感和一种控制感，而治愈不是我如何找到更好的方法来控制它，而是我如何释放控制，现在我们必须悄悄地谈论我们的水晶和释放控制。但归根结底，这就是它的本质。所以不确定性原则是一个
freaking game changer for me. And I hate it. I want no part of it it's the freaking worst and it's the best at the same time well I think that's how you and I mean it may not be the kind of stuff that you're doing but like with trauma therapy like I don't listen a ton to what people are saying as much as like what they're feeling and that's the thing is like you can you can figure out pretty quickly yeah you're afraid of not knowing what's going to happen tomorrow. And guess what? You don't know. Like you might get hit by a bus.
对我来说是一个改变游戏规则的东西。而且我讨厌它。我不想参与其中，它是最糟糕的，同时也是最好的。嗯，我认为这就是你和我的意思，它可能不是你正在做的那种事情，但就像创伤治疗一样，我并不太听人们在说什么，更多的是听他们的感受，这就是关键，就像你可以很快地弄清楚，是的，你害怕不知道明天会发生什么。猜猜怎么着？你不知道。就像你可能会被公共汽车撞到。
What does that do to you? What's going on in your body? You know, I'm not saying I hope you get by, by bus. I'm saying, let's not talk about what you're in control of. Let's talk about what you're running from because I'm expensive and you'd like to change, you know, by the hour friend. Yeah. And, and, and, but people will map that somatically so
那对你有什么影响？你的身体里发生了什么？你知道，我不是说我希望你被公共汽车撞到。我是说，让我们不要谈论你在控制什么。让我们谈谈你在逃避什么，因为我很贵，而且你想要改变，你知道，按小时计费的朋友。是的，而且，而且，而且，但人们会以躯体方式映射它
quickly i mean their posture just shows you you know like what what what happens to them and it's like it looks like you're wearing a backpack or it looks like you want to hide something or it looks like you want to just like go and disappear can i tell you that's just so interrupting during no this is an interrupting podcast. You want to push back. During one of my brain spotting sessions with my own therapist. And so just a little self-disclosure here. Most of my parts show up as cartoon characters, as animated characters or childhood characters, like from Never Ending Story. So if they're not animated, they're still very like, you know, the luck dragon.
很快，我的意思是他们的姿势就向你展示了，你知道，就像，发生了什么，看起来就像你背着一个背包，或者看起来你想隐藏什么，或者看起来你想只是，就像，离开并消失。我可以告诉你，这太打断了，在，不，这是一个打断的播客。你想反击。在我自己治疗师的一次大脑定位会议期间。所以这里有一点自我披露。我的大部分部分表现为卡通人物，作为动画人物或童年人物，就像来自《大魔域》。所以如果它们不是动画的，它们仍然非常像，你知道，幸运龙。
No, no anime. That was kind of a Gen Z thing. Yeah's more i'm i am not gen z i'm a zenial so i'm in that like weird sweet spot but um it would be more like oh but anyway so then my um my backpack literally showed up as this little disney character that like clung on my back and i was like and we just in that we knew he was my backpack but it's just i just you said you could physically see a person when they had their backpack and i had a somatic experience just you saying that and i was like oh my little backpack guy and like i can picture him and i'm like people who are watching the video are like god she's gesturing a lot yeah i like back before i did any kind of brain spotting or even emdr anything um i was doing like a lot of kind of brain spotting or even EMDR or anything,
不，不，动漫。那有点像Z世代的事情。是的，更多的是，我不是Z世代，我是千禧一代，所以我处于那个奇怪的甜蜜点，但是，嗯，它更像是，哦，但无论如何，所以我的，嗯，背包字面上表现为这个小迪士尼角色，它粘在我的背上，我就像，我们只是在那个中，我们知道他是我的背包，但这只是，我只是，你说你可以物理上看到一个人当他们有背包时，我有一个躯体体验，仅仅是你说的那个，我就像，哦，我的小背包家伙，就像我可以想象他，而且我像，正在看视频的人就像，天哪，她做了很多手势，是的，我喜欢在我做任何大脑定位或甚至EMDR任何事情之前，嗯，我正在做，就像很多大脑定位或甚至EMDR或任何事情，
I was doing like a lot of kind of like meditation as a stuff. And so like whenever there was somebody who came in that like, didn't know that they were angry, I would just start doing them because it was all customized to you. People I think thought I was going to buy a script or whatever, but it was like what you could see the semantic thing. But I'd always just be like, you're walking in the woods and the straps of your backpack are very hard very they're digging into your shoulders you feel it in your shoulder blades
我正在做很多像冥想一样的事情。所以，每当有人进来，就像，不知道他们很生气时，我就会开始做他们，因为这一切都是为你定制的。我想人们以为我要买一个剧本什么的，但它就像你可以看到的躯体东西。但我总是会说，你走在树林里，你的背包带子非常硬，非常，它们挖进你的肩膀，你在肩胛骨感觉到它
you feel it in your knees but only you can carry the backpack because you have to do it and you're resentful and you feel the sweat and i'll take the backpack off you know it's like because you can once you just make somebody feel the thing you can see how it's showing up somatically in their posture immediately and just help them well and that's the attunement piece right that's that's the attunement and i get on that soapbox all the time with my so i'm a brain spotting consultant as well so i help people go through the certification process right and i and i lead a free monthly consultation group on it and so many of our conversations around it are it's not the setup the setup is sexy because it's got this series of steps we can say well which setup is right for this and which setup is right for that it's the fun metaphor
你在膝盖感觉到它，但只有你能背着背包，因为你必须这样做，而且你很怨恨，你感觉到汗水，我会把背包拿下来，你知道，就像因为你可以，一旦你只是让某人感觉到那个东西，你就可以立即看到它在他们的姿势中以躯体方式表现出来，并帮助他们，嗯，那就是协调部分，对吧？那就是协调，我一直和我的，所以我也是一名大脑定位顾问，所以我帮助人们完成认证过程，对吧？而且我领导一个免费的月度咨询小组，我们关于它的很多对话都是，它不是设置，设置很性感，因为它有一系列步骤，我们可以说，嗯，哪个设置适合这个，哪个设置适合那个，它是有趣的隐喻
somebody came up with that they're proud of it's cool sounding but it's not the work and it well and it's it's not it's not it's not it's not the work and it's not the thing. It's the vehicle for the, the setup is the vehicle. The thing is the uncertainty and the attunement. Um, anyways, I'm not going to climb on that. Well, the uncertainty on the behalf of the clinician too,
有人想出了它，他们为此感到自豪，听起来很酷，但这不是工作，而且它，嗯，它不是，它不是，它不是，它不是工作，它不是那个东西。它是载体，设置是载体。那个东西是不确定性和协调。嗯，无论如何，我不会爬上那个。嗯，临床医生方面的不确定性也是，
because like I've said this before, but it's like, I was talking about for both of them. Oh, I can teach you how to hold the stick and I can teach you that when the pupil does this, then you maybe need to bounce a little bit or that you need to check the stick and I can teach you that when the pupil does this, then you maybe need to bounce a little bit or that you need to check and see if there's, if they actually are
因为就像我之前说过这个，但它就像，我是在谈论两者。哦，我可以教你如何拿棍子，我可以教你当瞳孔这样做时，那么你可能需要稍微弹跳一下，或者你需要检查棍子，我可以教你当瞳孔这样做时，那么你可能需要稍微弹跳一下，或者你需要检查并看看是否有，如果他们实际上是
on Adderall, even though they're saying they're not on Adderall or, you know, maybe it's just not whatever. Like I can tell you all that, but when the patient is liking it and going into the uncertainty and feeling a distressing thing that no one else has helped them connect with, and you put the stick down because I don't want to make people feel bad. You know, you haven't done your own work and you don't know that there's a good thing on the other side of the bad thing. I cannot teach you that. Go to therapy.
服用阿得拉，即使他们说他们没有服用阿得拉，或者，你知道，也许它只是不是什么的。就像我可以告诉你所有这些，但当病人喜欢它并进入不确定性并感觉到一个没有人帮助他们联系起来的痛苦事情时，你把棍子放下，因为我不想让人们感到难过。你知道，你没有做你自己的工作，你不知道坏事后面有一件好事。我不能教你那个。去接受治疗。
You're not ready to do brain spotting. Yeah. Well, and you haven't, I would say on top of that, maybe you've not had that experience for yourself and go get a practice partner and experience it. Because the second you have that, you're like, oh my God,
你还没有准备好做大脑定位。是的。嗯，而且你还没有，我会说除此之外，也许你还没有为自己有过那种体验，去寻找一个练习伙伴并体验它。因为一旦你有了那个，你就会像，哦，天哪，
I'm so glad that person did not move that pointer. I will share. I had that. And I, a lot of times when I'm assisting with, with pie fry, I'll share this experience because in my very, my very first phase one, my very first demo or practicum, right. It was the outside window. And I looked everywhere except for that pointer.
我很高兴那个人没有移动那个指针。我会分享。我有过那个。而且，很多时候当我协助派派（Pi Fry）时，我会分享这个体验，因为在我非常，我非常的第一阶段一，我非常的第一演示或实习，对吧。那是外窗。我看了除了那个指针之外的任何地方。
I mean, I was all over the place, but I always knew where it was. And I always felt really appreciative that the person just held it there because it felt like it kept me. It is the thing that kept me from flying into outer space, which we would call, you know, it kept me from flying out of my window of tolerance would call, you know, like kept me from flying out of my window of tolerance or, you know, moving in and out of dissociation. But it was like, I needed it there more than I would have thought. I would have thought, okay, once you find the eye position, then like, there it is. But I needed that person to be holding that place. So I didn't have to manage that. It was like, I could go wherever and come back to it. And it was just a really, it was a really powerful experience.
我的意思是，我到处都是，但我总是知道它在哪里。而且我总是感到非常感激，那个人只是把它放在那里，因为它感觉就像它保持了我。它是让我不飞向外太空的东西，我们会称之为，你知道，它让我不飞出我的容忍窗口，会称之为，你知道，就像让我不飞出我的容忍窗口，或者，你知道，进出解离。但它就像，我比我想象的更需要它在那里。我会想，好的，一旦你找到了眼睛位置，那么就像，它就在那里。但我需要那个人保持那个位置。所以我不需要管理它。它就像，我可以去任何地方并回到它那里。而且这真的是一个，这真的是一个强大的体验。
And so going back to having had that experience, I will hold that thing until the end of time. And I'll be like, let me know when you're ready for me to put it down. And I don't know if you ever have this where, and I don't know if this is you too, where like there really always is a pointer within reach for me. And I will be holding it and I'll say, you know, okay. and just let me know when you're ready and they'll go okay and i don't know if they're okay meant i'm ready or okay i'll let you know so i'll hold it and hold it and eventually they'll be like
所以回到有过那种体验，我会一直拿着那个东西直到时间的尽头。而且我会说，当你准备好让我把它放下时告诉我。而且我不知道你是否曾经有这种情况，而且我不知道这是否也是你，就像，真的总有一个指针在我触手可及的地方。而且我会拿着它，我会说，你知道，好的。只要当你准备好时告诉我，他们会说好的，而且我不知道他们的好的意思是，我准备好了，还是好的，我会让你知道，所以我拿着它，拿着它，最终他们会说
you can put that down i'm like okay i will put it down because i take so seriously not putting it down until a person is ready for it. Yeah. Yeah. They're totally in control and they know that they're in control. You're holding the space. And similarly, when someone says, I need you to put that down and they mean it cause they can't like that is it
你可以把它放下，我就像好的，我会把它放下，因为我非常认真地对待在一个人准备好之前不把它放下。是的。是的。他们完全在控制之中，而且他们知道他们在控制之中。你正在保持空间。同样，当有人说，我需要你把它放下，而且他们是认真的，因为他们不能，就像那是
being up is what pushes them out of the window of tolerance. Yeah. I believe you. So wait, these are the ETT ones. Um, when you do the color stuff the color stuff yeah yeah yeah the traditional pointer too yeah well that um that so
处于上方是什么把他们推出了容忍窗口。是的。我相信你。所以等等，这些是ETT的。嗯，当你做颜色东西时，颜色东西，是的，是的，传统的指针也是，嗯，那个，嗯，那个，所以
when what do you see as like uh the place that therapy needs to go you know like you you have started you end up in brain spotting brain spotting like you're kind of describing the thing that i noticed where people who are open to brain spotting and get into it even if i know nothing else about them i know that they were okay with something that wasn't a hierarchical system of steps if this happens then do that do the 12 movements and then you, like I know that they're going to be open and that's generally going to be the kind of clinician that somebody's asking for when they say, you know, what's the first thing to look for? It's not that, I mean,
当，你认为治疗需要去的地方是什么，你知道，就像你已经开始，你最终在大脑定位，大脑定位，就像你正在描述我注意到的事情，那些对大脑定位开放并进入它的人，即使我对他们一无所知，我也知道他们对不是分层步骤系统的东西没问题，如果发生这种情况，那么做那个，做那12个动作，然后你，就像我知道他们会开放的，而且这通常会是某人要求的那种临床医生，当他们说，你知道，要寻找的第一件事是什么？不是那个，我的意思是，
I think brain spotting works for an amazing amount of people. It's like one of the wider nets out there, but even if you don't need that exactly, you're going to end up with somebody who's open to uncertainty, you know know and open to just letting something happen where a lot of the models don't make room and what do you see yourself and and just the profession like heading you know post post that oh that feels like a big question i see myself trying to remember that and this maybe is not at all what you were asking but it's where it goes which is case in point i see myself finding out more about the ways to make this accessible to people outside of the therapy room which is kind of what i love about the coaching aspect and about
我认为大脑定位对惊人数量的人有效。它就像外面更宽的网之一，但即使你不需要那个，你最终也会找到一个对不确定性开放的人，你知道，而且开放只是让某事发生，而很多模型没有空间，你认为你自己和，以及职业本身，你知道，走向哪里，哦，这感觉像是一个大问题，我看到自己试图记住那个，这也许根本不是你问的，但它就是去向，也就是案例点，我看到自己发现更多关于让人们在治疗室之外也能接触到它的方法，这有点像我喜欢教练方面和关于
how brain spotting doesn't much very unlike lots of other modalities where like the licensed clinicians have a lockdown on it it's not that way with brain spotting um for better or for worse kind of depending on who you talk to but i think that making it more widely communicated to people that it's it's not only for trauma and I and I tell people too part of how I picked brain spotting and and got into brain spotting is because I did not want to be a trauma therapist and you know I was a little baby therapist and I didn't want to deal with trauma and everyone who is a therapist is laughing right now going ha ha ha that's impossible it all stems from trauma right like people still say it. Yeah.
大脑定位不像许多其他模式那样，就像持证临床医生对它有锁定，大脑定位不是那样，嗯，好坏参半，取决于你和谁谈论，但我认为让它更广泛地传达给人们，它不仅是为了创伤，而且我也告诉人们，我选择大脑定位并进入大脑定位的部分原因是因为我不想成为一名创伤治疗师，而且你知道，我是一个小婴儿治疗师，我不想处理创伤，而每个是治疗师的人现在都在笑，说哈哈哈哈，那是不可能的，这一切都源于创伤，对吧？就像人们仍然这样说。是的。
And I got into the therapy space and I was like, well, shit, it turns out, which goes back to even with coaching, right? Like it's, if you're truly hitting, like not hitting people where it hurts, but like getting deep in with coaching, you're going to bump up against a little bit of trauma. It's really unlikely that you won't. Well, it informs your purpose in your life's trajectory and all the stuff you're going to coaching for, but there's difference in understanding how that informs your life and making it conscious and really trying to dig into somatic chunks of stuff that is hard to get out of the subcortical brain. I mean, there's just two different things,
我进入了治疗空间，我就像，嗯，该死，结果证明，这甚至回到了教练，对吧？就像，如果你真的在打击，不是在人们受伤的地方打击，而是像通过教练深入挖掘，你会撞到一点创伤。你不太可能不会。嗯，它确实通知了你生活中的目的和你的生活轨迹以及你为了教练而做的所有事情，但理解这如何通知你的生活和使它有意识，以及真正试图深入挖掘难以从皮层下大脑中取出的躯体东西，是有区别的。我的意思是，这只是两件不同的事情，
but yeah, you're in conversation with it.'s just right right but so working with a coach who has that background and knows even what to do when you do butt up against the trauma right but so what happened is i was you know i was having this realization of like well turns out i'm gonna be a trauma therapist because all of my clients have some varying level of traumatic experience that needs to be cleared out. Right. And my population also did not, I work with a lot of people and by the time I closed my practice, a lot of my clients did realize they had trauma. But when I was, you know, early starting on, there was a lot of like, not really like no no my life has been pretty good um not a lot of traumatic
但是的，你正在与它对话。就是对，对，但所以与有那个背景的教练一起工作，并且知道当你确实撞到创伤时该做什么，对吧？但所以发生的事情是，我，你知道，我有了这种认识，就像，嗯，结果证明，我将成为一名创伤治疗师，因为我所有的客户都有某种程度的创伤体验，需要被清除。对。而且我的群体也没有，我和很多人一起工作，到我关闭我的诊所时，我的很多客户确实意识到他们有创伤。但当我，你知道，早期开始时，有很多像，不是真的，就像不，不，我的生活一直很好，嗯，没有很多创伤
things have happened you know and then come to find out that things that maybe the broader world would not have called traumatic but were in fact very heavily traumatic for that person well i think trauma is like so it's become well i like that trauma is more the focus of therapy now and gets brought up a lot but i also feel like in doing that it's become too big of a word well yeah there's strain trauma there's acute trauma and there's also just like i know that like i mean half of yeah i'm calling all this trauma because it's become too big of a word but like you witness something in Iraq. Your buddy gets blown up.
事情发生了，你知道，然后发现那些也许更广泛的世界不会称之为创伤的事情，但实际上对那个人来说是非常沉重的创伤，嗯，我认为创伤就像，它已经变得，嗯，我喜欢创伤现在更多地成为治疗的焦点，并且经常被提出来，但我也觉得在这样做时，它已经变成了一个太大的词，嗯，是的，有压力创伤，有急性创伤，也有只是，就像，我知道，就像，我的意思是，一半的，是的，我称所有这些为创伤，因为它已经变成了一个太大的词，但就像你在伊拉克目睹了什么。你的伙伴被炸飞了。
You keep re-experiencing that as a flashback. That's PTSD. That's trauma. Okay? I see dad hit the wall one time and almost hit me. But then he never did hit me. But I thought he might. And I've got this strange trauma of that went on all the time.
你不断地重新体验那个作为闪回。那是PTSD。那是创伤。好吗？我看到爸爸有一次撞墙，差点打我。但他从来没有打我。但我以为他可能会。而且我有那种一直持续的奇怪创伤。
And so my body was ready for it even though it didn't happen but i didn't have the experience so i'm not allowed to have it so it's not where you're gaslighting yourself yeah so like i'm having a reaction to something that didn't really happen like self gaslighting which is also thoughts with me and cbt but anyways we're calling that strain trauma now right you know which i'm glad there's room for that but then there's also like everybody said the family is normal and fun and this is what it's good and it's supposed to be like this but i knew that it this wasn't normal and fun or right but i called it that with language in my head but i knew something was wrong
所以我的身体为它做好了准备，即使它没有发生，但我没有那种体验，所以我没有被允许拥有它，所以这不是你在对自己进行煤气灯效应，是的，就像我对没有真正发生的事情有反应，就像自我煤气灯效应，这也是我的想法和CBT，但无论如何，我们现在称之为压力创伤，对吧？你知道，我很高兴有空间容纳那个，但然后也有，就像每个人都说家庭是正常的和有趣的，这是好的，它应该是这样的，但我知道它不是正常的和有趣的，或者对的，但我用我脑子里的语言称它为那样，但我知道有什么不对劲
for 18 years and now i can't you know that is trauma too but it's like we're putting and then you know i could go on but you kind of know what i mean there um i do well and what you're making a case a point for you're making a case for my point which was most of my clients did not recognize their trauma and had and so i was sitting there like between emdr and brain spotting going okay which one you know am i gonna like set up shop with because i did not have the budget to do both and i knew my people my people i love them so much and they are googlers and they're going to research the shit out of anything and i knew the second they googled emdr it was going to be ptst veterans and all these
18年了，现在我不能，你知道，那也是创伤，但它就像我们正在放置，然后你知道，我可以继续，但你有点知道我的意思，嗯，我确实，嗯，而且你正在提出的案例点，你正在为我的观点辩护，那就是我的大多数客户没有认识到他们的创伤，并且有，所以我坐在那里，就像在EMDR和大脑定位之间，去，好的，哪一个，你知道，我要去建立商店，因为我没有预算做两者，而且我知道我的人，我非常爱他们，而且他们是谷歌搜索者，他们会研究任何东西，而且我知道他们谷歌EMDR的那一秒，它将是PTSD退伍军人和所有这些
things and they were going to immediately dismiss versus brain spotting they were going to immediately dismiss it versus brain spotting they were going to google and be like there's i don't really know like it's not really out there so i then tried to really hard tackle the seo in my area for brain spotting and i i dove straight into it because i wanted to be the first person to speak it into existence for the biggest variable for seo is time too yes so that i but so that i could speak it in a way that made it not about the trauma like yes it does that but it's so much more than that and i think that's true of all these support because people will be like well emdr is great for all that too like yeah no i'm not saying it isn't i'm saying if you google it good luck yeah that was why i that was how well the rigidity
事情，而且他们会立即驳回，而不是大脑定位，他们会立即驳回它，而不是大脑定位，他们会谷歌并像，我真的不知道，就像，它真的不在外面，所以我然后尝试真正努力解决我所在地区大脑定位的SEO，而且我直接潜入其中，因为我想成为第一个为SEO最大的变量也是时间的人，是的，所以我，但所以为了我可以用一种不关于创伤的方式说出来，就像是的，它确实那样，但它远不止于此，而且我认为所有这些支持都是如此，因为人们会像，嗯，EMDR对所有这些也很好，就像是的，不，我不是说它不是，我是说如果你谷歌它，祝你好运，是的，那就是为什么我，那就是刚性
like the emdr i mean one of the reasons that I left is that I was saying, hey, I'm noticing that the pupil wibbles here and that the person has a reaction on that spot. And when I stopped there, they visualized things from the experience. Do the 15 movements. They're holy and handed down by Shapiro. And you can't change the 15. And I was like, why am I i paying for 300 an hour for a consultation where you're telling me the number 15 over and over like i can read you know and there's no ability to to evolve you know i do and i do i
就像EMDR，我的意思是，我离开的原因之一是我在说，嘿，我注意到瞳孔在这里摇晃，而且那个人在那个点上有反应。当我停在那里时，他们可视化了来自体验的事情。做那15个动作。它们是神圣的，由夏皮罗传下来。而且你不能改变那15个。而且我就像，为什么我为一个咨询支付300美元一小时，你一遍又一遍地告诉我数字15，就像我可以读，你知道，而且没有能力进化，你知道，我确实，而且我确实，我
know many many emdr therapists who who are evolving with it and i think that's amazing i just think when people like you and David came out and said, Hey, I'm noticing this. It sounds like you just, it's a shame that you weren't met with more curiosity. Well, but Shapiro said, if you change EMDR, you're not doing my EMDR. You know, whereas David said, this is supposed to go on and change. And so, you know, the free spotting people can say they do brain spotting, but evolved EMDR, you know, according to the founder is not EMDR. Yeah. Well, and I don't know, I got out of the rabbit hole of EMDR.
知道许多许多EMDR治疗师，他们正在随之进化，而且我认为这很棒，我只是认为当像你和大卫这样的人出来说，嘿，我注意到了这一点。听起来你只是，很遗憾你没有遇到更多的好奇心。嗯，但夏皮罗说，如果你改变EMDR，你不是在做我的EMDR。你知道，而大卫说，这应该继续并改变。所以，你知道，大脑定位的人可以说他们做大脑定位，但进化的EMDR，你知道，根据创始人，不是EMDR。是的。嗯，而且我不知道，我从EMDR的兔子洞里出来了。
So I can speak to what my understanding is, but it's all going to be opinion, not informed decisions, which again, is my third pillar. So I try not to do it, but like, yeah, I do. I, I, that was how I stumbled into brain spotting. That was how brain spotting chose me is because I needed something that my people were not going to Google and immediately dismiss because they were already dismissing the fact that they had trauma, not dismissing, but they were already on this, on, on the stand, taking a stand of, that's not what I'm here for. I'm not here to process trauma. I'm not having flashbacks because they weren't having what flashbacks look like in the movie. Right. But, um, gosh,
所以我可以谈谈我的理解是什么，但这都将是观点，而不是知情的决定，这再次是我的第三个支柱。所以我尽量不这样做，但就像，是的，我确实。我，我，那就是我如何偶然发现大脑定位。那就是大脑定位如何选择我，是因为我需要一些我的人不会谷歌并立即驳回的东西，因为他们已经在驳回他们有创伤的事实，不是驳回，但他们已经在那个，那个，那个立场上，采取了一个立场，那不是我在这里的原因。我不是来处理创伤的。我没有闪回，因为他们没有电影中闪回的样子。对。但是，天哪，
that was a whole long conversation that's done that of us just talking about like, who else do I work with? Well, I think like brain spotting, you find the more things in the file because there is this openness like even if somebody googles emdr and they see somebody say actually you can use emdr for creativity and that's result number one on google you're still sitting there being like what do you want to treat where what is it like how is that affecting you what's the bad experience you know what's the thing with brain spotting it's just kind of like i don't know feel the energy look at a stick and then your body your your brain is just smarter than any analyst it's smarter than any patient your deep brain will tell you what it is and sometimes we really want it to be page one of the file and we're just talking
那是一场漫长的对话，那是我们只是谈论，我还能和谁一起工作？嗯，我认为像大脑定位，你在文件中发现更多的事情，因为有这种开放性，即使有人谷歌EMDR，他们看到有人说实际上你可以将EMDR用于创造力，那是谷歌上的第一个结果，你仍然坐在那里，就像你想治疗什么，在哪里，它是什么，就像那如何影响你，什么是糟糕的体验，你知道，大脑定位的事情只是有点像，我不知道，感受能量，看一根棍子，然后你的身体，你的大脑比任何分析师都聪明，它比任何病人更聪明，你的深层大脑会告诉你它是什么，有时我们真的希望它是文件的第一页，而我们只是在谈论
about that and talking about that in cbt or something and then you just like go for a minute and get the front of the brain out of the way and brain spotting is like here's all the other paper in that file man it's a lot of other things are on that same you felt trapped you know network which which full circle is so true around alcohol right like people think it's just about i don't want to crave it and i want to not have a craving and it's not it's it's it is so woven in and it is a web in social relationships and family relationships and our relationship to our business and our bodies. And it's, it's so woven in. It's really hard just to say, I just don't want to crave it, or I'm just going to take a break. That's, um, I know, and I'll wrap up soon. That's my,
关于那个，并在CBT或什么的谈论那个，然后你只是像去了一分钟，让大脑的前部离开，大脑定位就像，这是那个文件中的所有其他纸张，伙计，有很多其他事情在同一个你感到被困的，你知道，网络上，这全圆圈在酒精周围是如此真实，对吧？就像人们认为这只是关于，我不想渴望它，我想没有渴望，而且它不是，它，它被编织得如此紧密，它是一个在社会关系、家庭关系以及我们与生意和身体的关系中的网。而且它，它被编织得如此紧密。真的很难只是说，我只是不想渴望它，或者我只是要休息一下。那是，嗯，我知道，而且我会很快结束。那是我的，
one of my main soap boxes that I get on. And this is actually, I have a, in addition to the, what type of Groundhog Day dream for are you, I do have another free training I can share with anyone who's interested, but where I talk about three of these points, but one of my main points is if we're going to take a 30 day break from drinking, that to me, and we're going to call it a reset. And yes, there are physical things that happen in those 30 days. Like that is undeniable. But to me, that is, and we're going to finish the 30 days and then say, okay, now I'm going to go towards moderating, right?
这是我经常挂在嘴边的话题之一。实际上，除了“你是哪种土拨鼠日梦境类型”之外，我还有另一个免费培训可以分享给任何感兴趣的人，我在里面谈到了其中三个要点。但我主要想说的是，如果我们打算戒酒30天，对我来说，我们称之为“重置”。是的，这30天里确实会发生一些生理上的变化，这是不可否认的。但对我而言，当我们结束这30天，然后说“好吧，现在我要开始适度饮酒了”，对吧？
Because I've realized I don't need it. I don't want it as much. I'm much healthier without it. I feel so much better. But the problem is we've effectively taken our dirty laundry, shoved it in the corner for 30 days and said, well, yeah, now I don't smell it. I don't have to look at it like I don't have to deal with it. But the laundry is still not clean.
因为我意识到我不需要它，我没那么想喝它了。没有它我更健康，感觉好多了。但问题在于，我们实际上只是把脏衣服塞进角落里30天，然后说：“好吧，现在我闻不到它了，也不用看着它，不用去处理它了。”但衣服依然没有洗干净。
Like we didn't actually solve the problem. We just shoved it in the closet for 30 days. And then when we get it back out. To then say now these clothes are clean is it's a damn lie yeah well i mean what happens is your tolerance went down so you're drinking less just because it's affecting you more and it'll take you know three months for it to creep back up and then oh january's here again you know and then you're on groundhog day yeah well yeah i don't know it's it's it's it's interesting too because like the younger generations are pretty i mean you know things maybe could change but the data has stayed pretty consistent that
就像我们并没有真正解决问题，只是把它塞进衣柜里30天。然后当我们把它拿出来，说这些衣服现在干净了，这简直是胡扯。是的，我的意思是，发生的情况是你的耐受力下降了，所以你喝得少了，仅仅是因为它对你的影响更大了。这需要三个月的时间让它慢慢回升，然后哦，一月又到了，你知道的，然后你就又回到了“土拨鼠日”的循环里。是的，我不知道，这很有趣，因为年轻一代……我的意思是，你知道，事情也许会改变，但数据一直很一致，那就是
people drink less and there's certain things like they're savvy yeah like they're they're risk averse i mean some of it i think is that whatever you call it delta you know 10 or whatever but you know they can get marijuana easier some of them. But there's also just like there's a risk averseness. And like just looking at like market trends and things, things like wine, like when boomers sectors that have grown for like five years are like investment bottles, like over $300 a bottle and, and like buzz balls that you get at a gas station. But when we think about the genius of alcohol as a money-making franchise for a money-making company, like way to do it. When you start to realize the number of conversions you're about to have is going to decrease you better increase the price of every conversion and sell the more expensive stuff to maintain that i think
人们喝得更少了，而且他们很精明，他们规避风险。我想其中一部分原因可能是某种“德尔塔”之类的，或者他们更容易获得大麻。但也有纯粹的风险规避心理。看看市场趋势，比如葡萄酒，像婴儿潮一代，过去五年增长的领域是投资级瓶装酒，每瓶超过300美元，还有你在加油站买的那种廉价酒。但当我们思考酒精作为一种赚钱公司的摇钱树的“天才”之处时，这确实是种手段。当你开始意识到你的转化次数即将减少时，你最好提高每次转化的价格，并销售更昂贵的产品来维持利润，我想是这样。
i mean business wise it is astounding like i am in like all the admiration for the industry but i think what you're talking about too with with the younger generations or i guess they're not even that young anymore but i'm just that old they're old enough that they could be drinking if they wanted to. Exactly. There's this savviness because it's similar to, you know, those of us who grew up when the studies were able to tell us that like smoking was actually not healthy for you. Like we have that now we've got more hardcore evidence that alcohol just really has zero health benefits and any that we get touted or just
我的意思是，从商业角度来看，这令人震惊。我非常钦佩这个行业，但我认为你提到的关于年轻一代——或者我猜他们已经不算年轻了，只是我太老了——他们已经到了如果想喝酒就可以喝酒的年纪。没错。他们有一种精明，因为这类似于我们这些在研究告诉我们吸烟实际上对健康有害时成长起来的人。我们现在有了更确凿的证据，证明酒精确实没有任何健康益处，任何被吹捧的好处都只是
You're absorbing the benefits when you study it of socialization, extroversion, community, and then there's like a secondary effect, but you, every time they try and generalize it just to alcohol, you, you can't, it's not good for you. Nope. And that's why, that's why I get on my soap boxes because I know that there are people who it's not bad enough that they want to go to therapy or they want to go to therapy for their trauma and they're paying, you know, a zillion dollars an hour, which is well worth it. Right. Like, but they're picking and choosing what needs to come up in that hour and it's the trauma and the drinking is just kind of this other side thing where it's not problematic enough to warrant therapy time,
你在研究中吸收的是社交、外向、社区带来的好处，然后还有一种次要效应。但每次他们试图将其归结为酒精本身时，你不能这样做，它对你没有好处。不。这就是为什么我总是挂在嘴边，因为我知道有些人，他们的问题还没严重到需要去接受心理治疗，或者他们因为创伤正在接受治疗，每小时花费巨额费用，这当然很值得。对吧？但他们正在挑选在这一小时内需要谈论的内容，通常是创伤，而饮酒只是某种次要的事情，还没严重到需要占用治疗时间，
but it just nags at their brain and they end up on that groundhog day where it's like, okay, I'll try again today. Okay. Dry January is coming up. Yeah. Well,
但它一直在脑海中萦绕，最终让他们陷入了“土拨鼠日”的循环，就像是：“好吧，今天我再试一次。好吧，‘干燥一月’快到了。”是的，好吧，
and like, there's a lot of people who I think genuinely want to work on that, but they're not at the place where they need 12 step to be alive or employed or married or whatever. And they're afraid that if they go to a therapy office and say that, that they're going to be told you have to go to AA and come back. You're not ready to commit, you know,
而且我认为有很多人真心想解决这个问题，但他们还没到需要通过12步戒酒法来维持生命、工作或婚姻的地步。他们担心如果去心理咨询室说出这些，会被告知“你必须先去参加AA（戒酒互助会）再回来，你还没准备好做出承诺”，你知道的，
whatever. And yeah, I mean, maybe that's right. Some of the time, not every therapist who says that to somebody, they didn't need to hear it, but there are people who I think avoid therapy because they don't want to hear that and if they need something else i'm glad it's there yeah oh thank
无论如何。是的，我的意思是，也许有时是对的。并不是每个对病人说这话的治疗师都是错的，但确实有人因为不想听到这些而回避治疗。如果他们需要其他选择，我很高兴有其他途径。是的，哦，谢谢
you yeah that was well said yeah and i it's important to me to be part of why of how there is something else there for them yeah not to take away from any of these other methods but just to add and say there's a subset of people who, even if that were right for them, they're not going to do it. So we need to get them in another way. Yeah. You have anything else that you were working on or that you would like to talk about? I mean, brain spotting and gray area drinking are kind of what you're loud and proud about on the internet, but are there other kind of insights or questions you, I don't know. Yeah, no, I mean, I get loud.
你，是的，说得好。对我来说，成为他们能有其他选择的一部分很重要。不是要否定其他任何方法，只是作为补充，说有一部分人，即使那些方法适合他们，他们也不会去做。所以我们需要用另一种方式引导他们。是的。你还有什么正在进行的工作或者想谈论的话题吗？我的意思是，脑点疗法（Brainspotting）和灰色地带饮酒是你在这个领域最响亮、最引以为傲的标签，但还有其他见解或问题吗？我不知道。是的，不，我的意思是，我会大声疾呼。
The uncertainty principle. You're like, Oh gosh, don't, I will go all day on that. Mostly that. And then, like I said, the perfectionism and the business ownership thing and how a lot of it to me is people end up buying these like Aaron Condren planners and, you know, overhauling their schedule to try and be like their most productive version of themselves, especially business owners,, I want to get into, uh, you know, playwriting. I need to like buy 12 hours of David Mamet talking or something. And you're just kind of like, I don't know. We just have this weird thing where like, I don't know, why would you want to be like Steve Jobs? You know, like it just like, that's so many people. I get that there's aspirational things
不确定性原理。你会说：“哦天哪，别，我可以整天谈论这个。”主要是这个。然后，就像我说的，完美主义和企业主身份，以及对我来说，很多人最终购买像Aaron Condren那样的计划表，彻底重组他们的日程安排，试图成为最高效的自己，尤其是企业主。我想涉足剧本创作，我需要买12小时的大卫·马梅特（David Mamet）的讲座之类的。你只是觉得，我不知道。我们有一种奇怪的心理，为什么你会想成为史蒂夫·乔布斯？你知道，这就像很多人一样。我明白这些人身上有令人向往的东西，
about these people, but there's a lot of that kind of like the cult of the executive that is not healthy you know oh absolutely and a lot of well i'm not gonna go that was about to go straight back to alcohol you're right it isn't the thing i'm most loud and proud about because i think it's the first domino that needs to fall before these other things fall in place but to go back to this idea of business ownership right i have a i have a friend who I know who she calls it for her clients. They want to be time rich. And so that's why they aim for the CEO mindset, right? Cause then it's time wealth. It's, I started my business so I could have, I could afford the lifestyle I want and I don't have to be tethered to my business, right? Versus that hustle startup
但那种“高管崇拜”是不健康的。你知道，哦，绝对是。而且很多……好吧，我不会去谈那个，我本来想直接回到酒精话题。你是对的，这不是我最引以为傲的事情，因为我认为这是在其他事情步入正轨之前需要倒下的第一块多米诺骨牌。但回到企业主这个话题，我有一个朋友，她为她的客户称之为“时间富有”。所以这就是他们追求CEO心态的原因，对吧？因为那样就是时间财富。我创业是为了能负担得起我想要的生活方式，而不必被我的生意束缚，对吧？而不是那种忙碌的创业
mindset. And so I'm not, I don't want to steal her terms, but I was just like, oh, yeah, you nailed it. But so a lot of the business owners I work with, they're like they get in their own way with the perfectionism and the overthinking. And then they want to like color code a calendar because it's like, well, then I won't procrastinate. Procrastination is a huge thing. I brain spot with a lot of my clients is the business owner ones is the procrastination. Because we look at it similarly to not necessarily a trauma, but yeah, where it's like, well, there's some sort of like thing in you that's saying like, don't do like anything but that, right? Like it's an anger. So much of that avoidance is like, there's an anger that you kind of don't like what you're doing or how you're doing it or your relationship to it.
心态。所以我不想窃取她的术语，但我当时就想：“哦，是的，你说得太对了。”但我合作的很多企业主，他们因为完美主义和过度思考而阻碍了自己。然后他们想用颜色编码日历，因为觉得“这样我就不会拖延了”。拖延是一个巨大的问题。我与许多客户进行脑点疗法，特别是企业主客户，就是关于拖延。因为我们看待它的方式类似于——不一定是创伤，但确实是——某种内在的东西在说：“除了那个，做什么都行。”这是一种愤怒。很多回避行为就像是，有一种愤怒，你不太喜欢你正在做的事情，或者你做事的方式，或者你与它的关系。
Yeah. And then what happens is people try to figure it out. Well, am I angry at it? Is it because I'm afraid of success? Am I afraid of failure? All of those questions are in your top brain. And that is not where you need to make the switches. We need to get in the brain and body to make the switches.
是的。然后发生的情况是人们试图弄清楚它。我是对它感到愤怒吗？是因为我害怕成功吗？我害怕失败吗？所有这些问题都在你的大脑表层。而那不是你需要进行切换的地方。我们需要进入大脑和身体来完成切换。
So that's just kind of the that's kind of the next level of work i do with people is okay we've dealt with the alcohol now let's deal with any lingering perfectionism procrastination stuff yeah i think like we we think emotionally and we're like our thoughts come from emotion and then we figure out what they are with thinking but we pretend it's the other way around because it feels good because that's a sense of control it feels like i'm in control more than i am but then that's why i love and hate uncertainty well but we do it the opposite when we're dealing with like society things because that also makes us feel in control like people pretend that like politics is about values or something and it's like no i think it's about material reality whereas like with your body like in your brain like what you're thinking has so much more to do with what you're
所以这就是我与人们进行的下一阶段工作，即“好吧，我们已经处理了酒精问题，现在让我们处理任何残留的完美主义和拖延问题”。是的，我认为我们进行情绪化思考，我们的想法源于情绪，然后我们通过思考来弄清楚它们是什么，但我们假装是反过来的，因为这感觉很好，因为这是一种控制感。这感觉比实际情况更让我有掌控感，但这就是为什么我既爱又恨不确定性。好吧，但我们在处理社会问题时却反其道而行之，因为那也让我们感到有掌控感，就像人们假装政治是关于价值观之类的，而我认为它是关于物质现实的。然而对于你的身体和大脑来说，你的想法与你的
feeling and then you are rationalized not just rationalizing that that sounds like it's too reductive or writing it off too much but you're figuring out what that is later but i mean just look at the way that the brain is wired and running you were feeling first before you were in language or in time you know so start with that and and we pretend it's backwards that no i'm just going to think my emotional way i'm going to solve an emotional problem intellectually by talking about it and then eventually i'll feel different yeah and you know and there are people who because they thought about it differently not because they thought about it differently they thought about it differently, not because they thought about it differently, they thought about it differently,
感受有更大的关系，然后你稍后才将其合理化。这听起来可能太简化或太否定了，但你是在事后才弄清楚那是什么。我的意思是，看看大脑的运作方式，你在拥有语言或时间概念之前就已经在感受了。所以从那里开始。而我们假装是反过来的，认为“我要通过思考来解决情绪问题，通过谈论它，最终我会感觉不同”。是的，你知道，有些人因为他们思考的方式不同——不是因为他们思考的方式不同，他们思考的方式不同，他们思考的方式不同，
somewhere something shifted and they mistakenly assumed that was why it shifted. And so we're giving it the credit when that was a coincidence or a springboard for something else to happen, if that makes sense. And so it gets the credit sort of like, oh gosh, listen to how I really am like a soapbox person, aren't I?
在某个地方发生了转变，他们错误地认为这就是转变的原因。所以我们把功劳归于它，而那可能只是巧合，或者是其他事情发生的跳板，如果这说得通的话。所以它得到了功劳，就像……哦天哪，听听我，我真的像个爱说教的人，不是吗？
Learning so much about myself on your podcast? So much like the idea that dry January gets the credit for a reset for drinking when really it's not like we're giving the credit to something that didn't do anything. It was a vehicle, but it didn't do the thing. We have to get, we have to figure out what did the thing and then focus on building that skill, which I think is what you're saying. Yeah. I mean, analytical therapy is where that happens. I mean, Irvin Yalom used to say, you just let them talk until they feel and they'll say, it doesn't matter what they're saying. They'll say the same thing.
在你的播客上学到了很多关于我自己的东西？非常像那种观点，即“干燥一月”为戒酒重置赢得了功劳，而实际上并非如此。我们把功劳归于一个什么都没做的事情。它是一个载体，但它并没有完成那个任务。我们必须弄清楚是什么完成了任务，然后专注于建立那种技能，我想这就是你想表达的。是的，我的意思是，分析心理治疗就是发生这种情况的地方。欧文·亚隆（Irvin Yalom）过去常说，你只需要让他们谈话，直到他们感受到，他们会说，他们说什么并不重要，他们会说同样的话。
And then all of a sudden they'll feel it or something. And I love a good Yalom quote. I love a good Yalom quote. Well, like there were, like, I remember listening to like seventies, you and gain analysts, like tapes, like they were, I were digitized when I had them in in college but they were like literally like ripped off cassette tapes and you could hear like the rewind scrub and stuff um but they were like one of the things like they would all agree on that at the time i was like what are you talking about and now it makes sense was that like the patient only changes in this place in between being awake and being asleep and you see them
然后突然之间他们就会感受到它或者其他什么。我喜欢亚隆的名言。我喜欢亚隆的名言。好吧，就像我记得听过七十年代的分析师录音带，我在大学时把它们数字化了，它们真的是从磁带上翻录下来的，你可以听到倒带的摩擦声，但它们就像是……当时他们都同意的一点，我当时想“你在说什么”，现在看来很有道理，那就是病人只在清醒和睡眠之间的那个状态下才会改变，而你看着他们
in the room for two years. Mom made me feel small anyway because of this mom made me feel small. And then all of a sudden like, whoa, mom made me feel small. And they felt it. And, you know, brain spotting takes you into this place between waking and asleep. But a lot of people feel like they're going to sleep
在房间里待了两年。“妈妈让我感到渺小，因为这个，妈妈让我感到渺小。”然后突然之间，“哇，妈妈让我感到渺小。”他们感受到了。你知道，脑点疗法把你带入这种清醒与睡眠之间的状态。但很多人觉得他们快要睡着了
or their clock stops and they lose time. You know, like it's that part of the brain that is informing what we do, but where the ego is so afraid to let go and admit that it isn't in control. You know, which is the uncertainty principle again. Yes, it is. And again, that goes back to that third pillar of the trifecta, right? Which is like there is a difference between knowing something and knowing it.
或者他们的时钟停止了，他们失去了时间感。你知道，正是大脑的那部分在影响我们的行为，但自我（ego）太害怕放手并承认它并不在掌控之中。你知道，这又是那个不确定性原理。是的，确实如此。这又回到了那个三位一体的第三根支柱，对吧？即“知道某事”和“真正领悟它”之间是有区别的。
And that's the same thing you're talking about is like I can say it and say it and say it and then one day i freaking say it and i feel it when i say it and so it's how do we facilitate that process well and i think like when people get a self-help book or they go on a certain kind of like religious or like secular you know life change course kick or you know executive coaching like whatever that's so much of the thing that actually happens is it gets you outside of yourself enough to have some perspective. And then it looks like it was the 17 step for success, you know, tier that you got to spend $5,000 to get the blue scarf or whatever. But really you just saw yourself differently because you did something different.
这和你刚才说的是一回事，我可以一直说一直说，然后有一天我真的说出来了，而且我在说的时候感受到了它。所以我们如何促进这个过程？好吧，我认为当人们拿到一本自助书，或者参加某种宗教或世俗的生活改变课程，或者高管教练课程时，真正发生的事情是它让你跳出了自我，从而获得了一些视角。然后看起来像是那套“17步成功法”起了作用，你花了5000美元买了那条蓝色围巾之类的。但实际上，你只是因为做了不同的事情，从而以不同的方式看待了自己。
And like that could be free or a lot less. It could. something different and like that could be free or a lot less it could and i think i think it's out there for free and i think there's enough about thing in the work i do out there for free that someone could probably piece it together for themselves and make it happen and i'm happy about that and what i virtually basically sell is well i can walk you through it a little bit faster than your trial and error method of figuring out how to make it work and i think that's true of therapy right like you know that well that's not always true of therapy because we don't heal in a vacuum and we need that relationship and that rapport i think is really important but the that's true of cbt let
这可能是免费的，或者成本低得多。它可以。做些不同的事情，这可能是免费的，或者成本低得多。它可以。我认为这些信息在外面是免费的，而且我所做的工作中也有足够多的免费内容，有人可能可以自己拼凑起来并实现它，我对此感到高兴。我实际上卖的是……好吧，我可以引导你，比你自己通过试错法去摸索如何让它起作用要快一点。我认为治疗也是如此，对吧？你知道，那并不总是适用于治疗，因为我们不是在真空中治愈的，我们需要那种关系和融洽感，我认为这非常重要。但那是CBT（认知行为疗法）的真理，让我
me put it that way cbt but i think you can cbt yourself if you have the right information but it's a lot of guess and check and trial and error and then of course there's cbt is not the part of brain we want anyways but it's an it's an analogy anyway okay we should start wrapping sure yeah i want to be respectful of your time. I can let you go. Yeah, no, I don't know. I think that's true though. That the, the way that the, the, the models of therapy that are actually new, cause a lot of them it's, you're just kind of putting something in new paper or whatever.
这样说，CBT。但我认为如果你有正确的信息，你可以对自己进行CBT，但这需要大量的猜测、核对和试错。当然，CBT也不是我们想要的大脑部分，但这只是一个类比。好吧，我们应该开始收尾了。当然，是的，我想尊重你的时间。我可以让你走了。是的，不，我不知道。但我认为那是真的。那些真正新的治疗模式，因为很多模式只是换汤不换药，
But like the ones that are actually new is where somebody, you can see the therapist tried this and this and this and this and none of it worked. And then they did this thing that worked for them. And then they were like, what was that? How do I say it? And how do I replicate it? And then, ta-da, you know, you have, you know, Eric Erickson or something. And like those are, they're all attempts to go back to the place where you healed and then share it with other people when they're genuine, you know, and you know, the cult, the cults are the exploitive modalities are the ones where somebody is appropriating the language of healing and change to, and somebody who hasn't done it can't tell the difference.
但那些真正新的模式是，你可以看到治疗师尝试了这个、那个，都没有用。然后他们做了这个对他们有效的事情。然后他们会想：“那是什么？我该怎么说？我该怎么复制它？”然后，塔达，你知道，你有埃里克·埃里克森（Eric Erickson）之类的。这些都是试图回到你治愈的地方，然后在它们真实的时候与他人分享，你知道，那些邪教、剥削性的模式是那些挪用治愈和改变的语言的人，而没有经历过的人无法分辨区别。
So, you know, of course. Yeah. They're getting very well said. I like that. Make that a soundbite. Yeah. I'll send you a little clip. Yeah.
所以，你知道，当然。是的。说得太好了。我喜欢这个。把它做成一个短音频片段。好的，我会发给你一个小片段。好的。
Well, I really appreciate you coming on. If people want to get your services or find out more about you, like your free consultation group with their provider, you know, what, what do you, what do you want them to go? We can link to anything in the show notes. So definitely check those out. But we want to, we want to tell us some places where we can find out more about what you do and definitely tell us about your podcast.
好吧，非常感谢你来参加。如果人们想获得你的服务或了解更多关于你的信息，比如你的免费咨询小组，你希望他们去哪里？我们可以在节目说明中添加任何链接。所以一定要去看看。但我们想让你告诉我们一些可以了解更多关于你所做工作的地方，一定要告诉我们你的播客。
Absolutely. Yeah. So the easiest way to find me the fastest is probably Instagram. And I'm just at Carolyn Robisto. I say it's the fastest because it's the easiest. It's just my name. There's no hyphens or anything. Just it's my name. Go find me. And every other way under the sun to connect with me is on there in some way, shape or form. So it's kind of like the, the easiest one-stop shop. Including my podcast. My website is Carolyn Robistow, but it's.net, not.com. I slept on that. I actually got rid of that calm and then I couldn't get it back. And I was like, Oh, there you go. That's what happens.
当然。是的。找到我最快的方法可能是Instagram。我就是@CarolynRobistow。我说它是最快的，因为它是最简单的。就是我的名字。没有连字符或任何东西。就是我的名字。去找到我。所有其他联系我的方式都在上面，以某种形式存在。所以它就像一个最简单的一站式商店。包括我的播客。我的网站是CarolynRobistow，但后缀是.net，不是.com。我当时没注意，后来我放弃了那个.com，就再也拿不回来了。我就想，哦，好吧，这就是发生的事情。
But my podcast is called brain unblocked. And if you thought this was a soapbox, boy, I tell you what, there's 70 some odd episodes over there. Plenty more soapboxes about it. So come join me. Well, great. We'll link to all of that stuff. And if there is if there's anything else, send it to me and I'll link it in the show notes. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但我的播客叫《Brain Unblocked》。如果你觉得这像是在说教，天哪，我告诉你，那里有70多集节目。还有更多关于它的说教。所以来加入我吧。好的，太棒了。我们会链接到所有这些内容。如果还有其他什么，发给我，我会把它放在节目说明中。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。